neo4j is a powerful graph database that
enables organizations to model store and
analyze complex relationships between
data points its intuitive graph-based
structure offers a flexible and
efficient solution for diverse
applications making it a leading choice
for managing connected data this course
is taught by freecocamp team members
Farhan choudhary and Gavin long first
you will learn about neo4j and graph
database Management Systems as well as
how you can benefit from incorporating
them into your applications next you
will learn how to use a neo4j graph
database management system as the
back-end storage for a real world
application created with Java and spring
boot finally you will learn how to
create a front end with react to
interact with the data store with neo4j
neo4j provided a grant to make this
course possible so let's get started
hi and welcome I'm Gavin long so I
finally got my free code Camp t-shirt I
traveled all the way from the east coast
of South Africa to Amsterdam and met the
founder of free code Camp Quincy Larson
and he gave me my own free code Camp
t-shirt really great
so the point of the trip was to meet
Quincy and some of the core team members
of free code camp in person
it was about team building and
solidifying relationships between
co-workers the key Concept in this
course is in fact relationships
relationships between data the
relationships could be between people
between car parts between a T-shirt and
a human being
so relationships between homogeneous
data or lack data for example between
human beings or relationships between
heterogeneous data or different types of
data these relationships can be very
effectively represented within a graph
database management system
neo4j is a graph database management
system
in this part of the course I want to
present to you a brief overview
highlighting the significance of a graph
database management system before we
look at neo4j let's contextualize the
significance of a graph database
management system by looking at some of
the other popular types of database
Management Systems commonly used today
so let's look at three other commonly
used types of database Management
Systems before we discuss the graph
database management system
and why we would want to use a graph
database management system in our
applications
the most well-known used database
management system type is a relational
database management system examples of
relational database Management systems
are SQL server postgres and MySQL
in this type of database tables
represent entities for example a table
named employee contains rows of data
each row of data is divided into columns
or Fields containing employee
information for example the name field
contains the employee name the age field
contains the employees age Etc another
data entity could be implemented in a
table named Department each row in the
Department's table denotes an individual
department for example one row stores
information for the human resources
department at another row stores
information for the finance department
these data entities or database tables
within a relational database can be
explicitly related to one another within
the relational database management
system for example an entity may have a
one-to-one relationship with another
entity
so say employees and the cars they drive
a specific employee is related to a
specific car one employee to one car
so for example the employee entity in
this case has a one-to-one relationship
with the car entity
two database tables can have a
many-to-many relationship for example an
employee could be a member of multiple
teams and each team can contain multiple
employees so this means an employee can
be a member of more than one team and
each team can have many employees so in
this scenario the employee entity has a
many-to-many relationship with the team
entity
a database entity can have a one-to-many
relationship with another database
entity
for example the department table has a
one-to-many relationship with the
employee table meaning each department
can contain one or many employees and an
employee can only be a member of One
department at a given time
so this one-to-many relationship can be
established within the relational
database management system through an
appropriate schema design a database
schema defines how data is organized
within a relational database which
includes constraints such as table names
Fields data types and the relationships
between the relevant entities so for
example the one-to-many relationship
between the department table and the
employee table can be implemented by
including a primary key which is a
unique identifier for a row of data in
the department table and a foreign key
field within the employee table which
relates to the primary key value within
the department table the main advantages
of a relational database design is that
it helps facilitate data Integrity so
the data is not easily corrupted as well
as reduces data redundancy storage for
repeated values are reduced for example
if you stored Department data within the
employee table you can see here the
department short name field and long
name field values are repeated across
rows in the employee table whereas
separating the data into an employee
table and a department table means these
values are not repeated resulting in
Saving storage space as the data scales
the storage saving can be quite
significant
a technique known as normalization is
employed to design a relational database
I won't go into the details of
normalization here but please look up
normalization which is a key Concept in
relational database design so the
technique of normalization can increase
data Integrity minimizing data
corruption and also significantly
reducing data redundancy I.E
unnecessarily storing values repeatedly
the downside to relational databases is
the speed of retrieving data when
multiple joins or deep joints between
entities are necessary for example if
you want to retrieve analytical data
that summarizes data from multiple
entities a normalized database design
can cause the retrieval of such data to
be a slow process so way to speed up
data retrieval can be to use a
schemaless database management system
like for example mongodb this is a
document-based database management
system
the fact that the database design is not
bound by a schema like with a relational
database management system can result in
increased speed of data retrieval as
well as allow for better design
flexibility so you can see that each of
these database Management Systems have
their purpose and advantages
another type of database management
system may use a name value pair storage
structure like for example redis
this database management system is great
for caching frequently retrieved data
and therefore can help speed up a system
so we have briefly looked at three
common types of database Management
Systems relational database Management
Systems like for example SQL server or
postgres schema lists database
Management Systems like for example
mongodb
and name value pair database Management
Systems like redis so let's look at the
significance of a graph database
management system neo4j is a graph
database management system this type of
database management system is based on
the graph data structure all of these
social media platforms use graph
databases Twitter Facebook and Instagram
as we all know these platforms have
millions of users a relational database
management system would not be ideal as
the only storage facility for such data
because of the way the data is
structured would mean multiple joints
between entities would need to be made
when relevance data is retrieved which
would drastically slow down the data
retrieval process ultimately causing a
poor ux user experience because the
whole system is slowed down by these
joints that need to be made between data
so note that when designing a particular
system like a social media platform you
could incorporate both a graph database
management system and a relational
database management system into your
overall system design this type of
solution could combine the enforced data
Integrity inherent and relational
database management systems with the
complex relationships between data
entities or nodes that can be
facilitated using a graph database
management system for example the master
database could be a relational database
where data integrity and data redundancy
concerns are addressed by the inherent
benefits that we have discussed
regarding a relational database
management system
a graph database management system that
is appropriately synchronized with the
relevant relational database management
system can be leveraged to increase the
retrieval speed of data that for example
has complex relationships if data that
requires complex relationships was
retrieved directly from the relational
database management system the joins
required when retrieving the relevance
data could significantly slow down the
system and ultimately result in a very
poor ux user experience so by including
a graph database management system in
the overall system where it sits on top
of the relational database management
system as it were and is used to speed
up the retrieval of data with complex
relationships this could significantly
speed up the data retrieval process
resulting in a far better ux user
experience so this sort of system would
require that the data stored in the
relevant graph database management
system and the relevant relational
database management system be
synchronized so as to ensure that the
data is consistent across the two
different database Management Systems so
a system like this when designed
properly can leverage the benefits of
both types of database Management
systems for graph-based data structures
a database management system that
focuses on the facilitation of
relationships between entities or nodes
is essential and a graph database
management system provides a way to
store data based on the graph data
structure which is ideal for
applications that consume data where
entities have multiple relationships and
complex relationships with one another
think about social media platforms where
you have relationships between users and
posts likes friendships Etc and you have
millions of people using these platforms
a database management system is needed
that appropriately facilitates the
storage of data for a large number of
different types of relationships a graph
database management system allows for
relationships to be stored as data
within the graph database with a
relational database management system
the emphasis is on the entities and
generally the relationships between the
entities are not stored in the database
but rather General relationships are
established at the design level for
example you can see by the foreign key
field value that the employee is a
member of the HR department but there
are no details about the relationship
itself between the relevant department
and the employee saved in the database
this is something you could easily do
within a graph database management
system you could create a more detailed
relationship
you can easily save data regarding
individual relationships between
entities or nodes for example between an
employee node and a Department's node so
here is a whiteboard presentation that
shows how the relationships between
individual employees
and employees and departments could be
represented within a graph database
so here we see a node that represents a
department this node is appropriately
labeled Department
details related to this department node
can be saved to the database as
properties and related values so this
department contains a short name
property with a value of HR and a long
name property with a value of Human
Resources
here is our first employee node this
node is appropriately labeled employee
the employee node contains properties
and relevant values representing the
employee's name and age
here we see our first relationship this
relationship explicitly shows that the
employee whose name is Brad Jenkins is
part of the HR department
this relationship is appropriately
labeled member of
so you can see that this is a very human
readable representation of data the fact
that this employee is a member of the HR
department is clear
through appropriate labeling and
properties
so Brad Jenkins is a member of the HR
department
we are able to add properties to the
relationships themselves so the member
of relationship has a join date property
as well as an employee type property
you can see by this data when this
employee joined the Department and that
this employee has a permanent role and
is not for example a contractor here we
have the second employee node who has
the name Jenny Lane Jenny is also a
member of the HR department
we can save relationships between
employees within our graph database so
Jenny works with Brad we can also create
another works with relationship in the
opposite direction where Brad works with
Jenny
so you can see that we have a one
Department to many employees
relationship just like what was shown
earlier in the relational database but a
graph database is far more flexible in
terms of design when establishing
relationships between data points or
nodes not only can the entities contain
Associated data but the relationships
themselves can also contain data I.E
through properties and Associated values
so we could create even more complex
relationships between nodes for example
a chain of command hierarchical
structure related to our employee nodes
so here's an example of this where
employee James Stokes reports to another
employee Jenny Lane this is just a
simple example and of course this
hierarchical data structure could become
far more complex
so this presentation was only intended
to give you a basic idea of how much
more flexible the design of
relationships between entities can be
within a graph database and how complex
easily implemented within a graph
database
I want to show you a brief demonstration
of using Cipher to query a graph
database and to do this I'll firstly
create a neo4j database on my local
machine I'll use my Mac platform to
demonstrate this I'll contrast using
Cipher and neo4j with using SQL in the
SQL Server database which of course is a
relational database management system
firstly what is cipher Cipher can be
likened to SQL or structured query
language Cipher is a text-based
declarative language used for querying a
neo4j database
what is meant by a declarative language
a declarative language is a high-level
language that describes what a
computation should perform these
languages must follow strict semantic
rules must be structured in a particular
way
in order to be valid and for desired
results to be returned from the
relevance database management system for
example using SQL in order to bring back
all employee records from the employee
table you would appropriately execute
the following SQL code
the SQL statement simply returns all
rows and all columns from the employee
table
using Cipher if you wanted to return all
employee data you would use a query like
this this query would return all
employee nodes and relevant
relationships although When comparing
these two query languages they are of
course semantically different but
principally they are the same and that
the relevant declarative text-based code
is paused by the appropriate database
management system converted into
appropriate instructions that are
executed under the hood as it were and
the relevant results are then returned
from the relevant database I'd like to
demonstrate using Cipher within a neo4j
database I'll contrast executing Cipher
against the neo4j database with
executing similar queries against a
similar database implemented in a SQL
Server database you don't need to follow
along with this part of the course but
of course you can if you want to so if
you want to follow along you can install
neo4j on your Mac or Windows platforms
by following the instructions at this
URL I have already installed neo4j on my
Mac platform
if you want to install a free version of
SQL Server please navigate to this URL
but as discussed this part of the course
is only intended to be an overview and
not a detailed explanation so it's not
necessary to follow along with this part
of the course I've created these scripts
on GitHub for this part of the
demonstration so I'm going to copy this
script from GitHub and run it in neo4j
to generate My neo4j Graph database so
with the neo4j desktop let's create a
new project I'm going to call this
project sample project
then let's create a new database I'm
going to name my neo4j database company
DB
let's give our database a password then
let's press the create button
and now we need to start the database so
let's press the start button to do this
then to execute our Cipher queries let's
click this open button and open the
appropriate window from which we can
execute our Cipher queries
so the first thing we need to do is copy
the code for creating our graph database
so let's navigate to this appropriate
GitHub URL let's copy this code from
GitHub and appropriately paste the code
within the window that we can use to run
our queries through neo4j desktop
great and let's click the play button to
create our graph database excellent and
we are presented with appropriate status
information telling us that our graph
database has been created successfully
I'm going to run this script within SQL
Server to generate a similar database
the difference of course being that this
database is designed as a relational
database
so let's appropriately copy this SQL
code from GitHub
let's launch SQL Server management
Studio
let's run our SQL code to create our
database I've already created a database
named the company DB test
so I'm going to create a new database
named the company DB test 2.
then I need to change the relevant SQL
script to point to the new database that
I've just created let's press the play
button to run the script and create our
database tables and relevant data
great
so I'm going to run a few queries so
that you can get a basic understanding
of the differences and similarities
regarding Cipher and SQL so let's run
this query against the neo4j database
great this query brings back all the
employee nodes and relevant
relationships
in order to retrieve all employee data
from within the relevant SQL Server
database you could run a SQL query like
this
and let's say we wanted to retrieve
particular data about a particular
employee
so you could run this Cipher code like
this
within the SQL Server database you could
run a SQL query like this
okay so now the next query I'd like to
run is a little bit more interesting so
in both these two databases we have
expressed a hierarchical relationship
between employees in the neo4j database
this is implemented through the report 2
relationship established between
employees in the SQL Server database the
same hierarchical relationship between
employees is expressed but through the
use of what's known as a self-joining
table
so in this case the employee table joins
to itself through the relationship
between the report to ID field and the
ID field which stores each employee's ID
so in the employee table the
hierarchical relationship between
employees is established through the use
of the reports to ID field which stores
the employee ID of the relevant
employees immediate boss if you like so
employee Brad Jenkins is at the bottom
of the hierarchy as it were so if you
wanted to query the SQL database to get
the chain of command from Brad Jenkins
to the top of the hierarchy you need to
run a query like this
as you can see this query is really
difficult to understand at first glance
and recursion is used to get the desired
results
a graph database is far easier to
understand in terms of retrieving such
tree data structures from the relevance
database
so to use Cipher code to retrieve the
relevant hierarchical data starting with
an employee at the bottom of the
hierarchy Brad Jenkins you would run
Cipher code like this against this
particular database
great okay so I hope this part of the
course has given you at least a basic
understanding of a graph database
management system and how you can
benefit from incorporating a graph
database management system into your
applications Farhan will now go into
more detail where he'll use a neo4j
graph database management system as the
back-end storage facility for the
server-side part of a real-world
web-based application I will then follow
Farhan and create the front-end code for
this application using react
hello everyone welcome to this course I
am Farhan hassin showed you one of the
instructors and I will walk you through
the entire process of working with a new
4G database as well as the development
of an API powered by Spring boot
framework
now at this point of the course I will
show you how you can create a new
account for the neo4j aura Cloud
database service
how to create a new database and run
some simple queries
now keep in mind that this is not going
to be an exhaustive list of all the
commands and queries that you can run
inside in your 4J database what I am
going to do is I will show you how you
can create a node how you can create
relationships how you can delete a node
update a node and some other basic crowd
operations in a word I will teach you
whatever is necessary to create the API
now to begin with we will navigate to
neo4js website I will leave the link in
the description so you can follow along
and once you are here you will use the
get started free button to create a new
account now start free and if you wish
you can sign up for a new account using
your email address but what I am going
to do is I will just use my Google
account to log in now I have
successfully logged into neo4j Aura and
I hope you have done that too so this is
the dashboard that they give us you can
see there are the instances that we are
going to create Now to create a new
instance of a database just click on the
new instance button and it will give you
a free templates like if you are a
beginner you can start here and it will
give you some data to start with what we
are going to pick is an empty instance
because I want to show you how you can
create new nodes relationships labels
and things like that
so we will hit create then they will
generate a password for us now you can
copy that password using this button
or even better you can use this download
button to download all the credentials
as a text format now I am not going to
do that yet but I will show you later on
how that works out
so once you have copied the credentials
click on confirm I have copied or
downloaded the above credentials so that
they will know that you have the
treatment Shields because you you cannot
get it once you have gone past this step
now you need to continue
now the creation process of a new
instance is a bit long it can take
around a minute or so so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to pause the
recording and come back once the
instance has been created
so it looks like that the database has
been created uh it's it's running on gcp
or Google Cloud platform and since I am
from Asia I am from Bangladesh
the region closest to me was Singapore
now we also have a connection URI now to
connect to this instance all you have to
do is click on the open button but
before that just in case you want to
rename your instance you can go here
and you can use rename I am not going to
do that though so I will just open it
and they will ask for a password so I
will just paste in my password
and the database user will be neo4j
you don't have to change any of these
things just click connect now once you
have landed on your workspace you will
see that there are no notes and
relationships whatsoever
but I would like to show you how you can
create new nodes how you can create new
relationships between them how you can
update a node now the cipher query
language is really expressive and this
is really easy to learn if you have
experience with some other query
languages like SQL but even if you do
not have any experience with that Cipher
is not that hard to learn the cipher
documentation is an excellent piece of
resource they also have a cheat sheet
now I will leave a link to this cheat
sheet in the description of this video
you can visit these and you can
essentially learn about how to read all
the notes in a database using the match
clause
or how to filter them using where return
variables
and under write queries you can also
learn about creating new nodes levels
and relationships
set for updating them delete and remove
for getting rid of notes and labels and
things like that I would suggest that
you bookmark this Cipher cheat sheet in
your browser so that you can refer back
to it whenever you need and also the
documentation now I will go back to our
workspace and I will start creating a
bunch of node and I will explain how you
can do that as well
so let's switch back to our workspace
and the first thing that we want to do
is we want to create a new node so we
will begin with the create class and a
set of parentheses
then we will put a colon here and we
will write the label of the node so a
node is an independent or a single
entity inside your database and it has
to be labeled something
for example if we create a node in our
database with the name Farhan has in
children it would be hard to say what
this node represents does it represent a
user does it represent someone's pet cat
what is it
so we are labeling our node with the
label user
and then we will put some properties
here the first thing I want to put is a
name for this user so Farhan
Name colon
Farhan hasin Chaudhary then I will put a
comma the next is a username this is a
unique username and we will use it to
uniquely identify every single user so
we will say username is just farha and
that's all I am going to put here now I
will execute the command using the play
button
and looks like we have a new label here
and if I click on this it will return
everything under this label to us now
instead of clicking on this label we can
also use the match class so we will say
match
and we want to match for all the nodes
in our database we use a return
all the nodes now this is just a
variable by the way if you want to call
it nodes
nodes you can do that as well just make
sure you are not using any of the
reserved keywords for example if I
remove the Acer you will see it becomes
red which means it's a keyword like
match and return we cannot use it so I
will change it back to notes I will run
the query and as you can see we have all
our nodes here
now let's go ahead and create two more
users so I will say create
and this time I want to actually create
multiple users with a single create call
so I will keep pressing shift and press
enter to come on the next line
I will start a set of parentheses I will
create a new user with the name
John
and his username
will be
just John
then outside of the last parenthesis I
will put a comma
and I will again keep pressing shift and
press enter to come to the second line
and I will open another set of
parentheses I will create another user
and her name
will be chained
and username will be just J
it has to be stream
now if I end this query with a semicolon
at the end I can just press on this play
button
and as you can see I have successfully
created two new nodes
at four sets of properties so if I say
match
in for notes and return in
I can get all the nodes in our database
so I have foreign I have John and I have
Jane now the thing is all these three
nodes are of the user level
so it would be nice to have another
label on our system so let's go ahead
and create a bunch of courses
Now to create a course we will use the
same
syntax as before and you can use your up
Arrow to bring back your old queries
I will just make some changes to this
query I will switch user with course
in both cases
I will replace title
we
C plus plus course
and the username with identity fire
this is an unique identifier for the
course which is CPP and the next course
we will have is title
Java Script
course and we can call it Js
finally we can have another course
called
C sharp course
and
its identifier
will be C sharp
whether I have made a mistake here it
should be identifier I'm not username so
let's look at our query we are creating
three courses with title C plus plus
course Java Script codes and C sharp
ports they all have uh unique identifier
cpp.js and c-sharp so I execute this
command
uh looks like I have a mistake which is
I didn't put a comma at the end and how
did I know that so it as you can see
neo4j is actually telling me that there
is some problem in the beginning of the
course title C sharp line but I can see
that it's totally fine so it's highly
likely that the mistake is actually at
the end of the previous line so that's
how I thought that maybe I have missed a
comma so I will run this query again and
I have created three new nodes and I
will say match
in and I return
in
so as you can see I have all my notes
Here There is Jane John and Farhan has
seen jewelry these are the users and C
plus plus JavaScript and C sharp these
are my courses now it would be nice if I
could create a relationship between Jane
and this C plus plus course John and
JavaScript and foreign C sharp course so
I want to essentially enroll them in
this course
but before that I would like to show you
a few variation of the match Clause so
right now when we say match in return in
it actually returns all the nodes in our
database
what if I want to only get the course
notes or the user nodes we can do that
by
defining a label after this variable
like this so I want all the users
return in as users you can actually do
that if you use as
you can actually rename your variables
to make them more user friendly so I am
matching all the node of label user and
I returning them as users I'll press
play
as you can see I am now getting only the
users and not the courses
likewise I can replace n with C or let's
just keep it n
since that's just a variable
I am picking the course as instead of
users I will say courses
by the way you can press Ctrl enter to
execute your query without pressing the
play button so right now I am getting
only the courses
but what if I only want to get one user
for example I only want to match for the
user with username Farhan
so I can do that I can same match
you for user so I input user then I will
use the where plus this is used for
filtering or query results so I would
say fire U dot username
is equals Farhan
return
U as
far
so what I am doing essentially here is I
am matching for a user type
that has the username Farhan I am
putting it inside you and I am returning
U as farha let's run this query
and as you can see I am getting Farhan
has in two three back
now let's add a course to the mix so
after I am saying U colon user I can put
a comma start another set of parentheses
I can say
C
course
so where U dot username equals Farhan
and
C dot identifier is equals CPP
so return U comma C
but this time I am removing the as
pre-word
and what I'm doing here I am matching
for a user and a course
fire the username is equals Farhan and
course dot identifier is equals CPP
finally I am returning U and C let's see
if it works
as you can see we have successfully
found the C plus plus course and the
Farhan has into three users now we are
actually ready to create a relationship
between these two nodes
so I will bring back my old query
and instead of returning them
I want to say create
because I want to create a new
relationship and I will first take the
user
so here I have the user
then I will put a dash
then a set of square braces and inside I
will say colon
enrolled in this is the type of
relationship this user is going to have
with the course
so what we are doing we are matching for
a user and a course where the username
is Farhan and course identifier is CPP
then we are creating a relationship what
kind of relationship you say we are
creating an outgoing relationship from
the user and how do I know that as you
can see there is an arrow going out from
the user towards the course so this is
an outgoing relationship from the user
and what is the type of this
relationship the type is actually
enrolled in
now we can actually save this
relationship inside a variable called r
and I can say return
r
so if I press the play button again
yes looks like I have successfully
created a relationship so the
relationship actually starts at Node 1
and ends at node 4 which means that the
ID of Farhan hasin choudhary is 1 and ID
of CPP is four if I go to user
you can see for Han hassin children has
the id1 and if I go to course
C plus plus course has the ID of four
okay and the type of relationship is
enrolled in there are no properties
whatsoever there are the element ID
start note element idea things like that
we do not have to worry about them
so that's how you can create a
relationship between
these two nodes
so that's how you can create
relationships inside of neo4j now let's
see how you can update a property of a
node so if I want to update the name of
Jane to Jane Doe and John to John Doe I
can do that
first we have to find John in our
database so we will say match
a variable U of type user
where
U dot username
equals John
so now we are matching for a user with
the username John
then we want to use set this is another
clause in neo4j Cipher language so it's
a set
U dot name
equals
John Doe
and if I execute this query
looks like it has done its job so if I
go back and instead of setting it if I
return
you
John has now become John Doe
we can do the same thing with Jane
because why not they are related
Jane and we can say
okay so I want to return J
return U
there you have it so now you have
learned how to match nodes in the
database you have learned how to create
new relationships update values of an
existing node now that's pretty much all
you are going to need for the API
development process but I would like to
show you one last Clause from The Cypher
query language and that is the exist
clause
for example if you ever want to check if
Farhan hasin tutori is enrolled in the C
plus plus course or not you can do that
using the exists Clause so we will begin
with match and what do we want to match
we want to match for an user
and we want to match for a course
where
U dot username sequels Farhan
and
C dot identifier is equals CPP
now we have an user with the username
Farhan and we also have a course with
identifier CPP next what we want to do
is we want to say
return
and we will call the exists function
this is a function and that's why we
have these two parentheses and inside
this parentheses we want to describe a
relationship
so the relationship we are looking for
or checking for is
whether user
is
enrolled in
the course or not
okay so you will finish our query what
we are doing we are matching for a user
with the username Farhan and we are
matching for a course with the
identifier CPP then you are checking
whether a relationship between them of
type enrolled in exists or not
so I'll press the play button
and it says true
now if I switch CPP for something else
like JS we have the JavaScript course
and I hit the play button
you will see I am getting false
now to be honest that's all you need to
know to go through this entire course
but Cipher is really excellent query
language and if you have plans to learn
a lot more neo4j than I have showed you
in this course I would suggest that you
go through the documentation you go
through their
cheat sheet and you practice making your
own databases creating them in a lot of
different scenarios and learn as much as
you can about this database system
now I am going to finish this lesson
here but in the next lesson you will see
me using an initializer Cipher script to
create a new database for our API
and from there we will begin working on
our Java code
in this part of the course we are
finally going to start working on our
spring boot API but before that we need
to set a few things up
first thing first go back to your neo4j
aura database dashboard and delete any
old instances that you may have created
while working with the API we want to
start with a clean slate so that we can
be sure of the fact that some old data
will not mess up our API to delete an
old instance you can use the delete
button here
and then you will have to write the name
of the instance
it's just to make sure that you are in
your right senses and you are not
sleeping or anything
click on the destroy button
and wait until the instance is being
destroyed
Now to create a new instance
use the new instance button
choose empty instance and click on the
create button
make sure you download the credentials
file because we are going to need it
later on
and also let them know that you have
downloaded the credential file by
clicking on this checkbox click on
continue
now creating a new instance may take a
few minutes so what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to speed up the process
in this video so that you don't have to
wait around for long
once the instance has been created click
the open Button
accept their terms and conditions
and when they ask for the password open
up the credentials file you just
downloaded
just highlight the password Here
copy it
and paste it on the empty password field
click on connect
and we have successfully connected to
our new instance
now as you can see this instance is
completely empty but we will need some
data to work on our API
for that I have already created an
initializer script that you can use to
initialize the database
for that
go to the code repository on GitHub I
will leave the link on the descriptions
below
then go inside the data folder
you will find a file called
initializer.cipher
open up this file
and go to Raw
highlight all the lines and copy with
Ctrl C
then go back to your aura DB dashboard
paste the code that you just copied
and then press the play button to
execute the code
as you can see the code has successfully
created some notes relationships and
property keys
now the first note that I would like to
show you is the user node
now this represents all the users in our
database
for example if we open up John Price you
can see that it has an ID
it has a name John price it has an
encrypted password hash
it has roles and it has username
now the significance of each of these
properties will become more clear as you
start working on the API but for now
just keep in mind that
all these properties are important for
our application
next up we have course
a this represent
each of the courses that will be
available on our system so if I click on
the Blazer shopping cart course you can
see that it has an ID of pen
it has a string identifier that we are
going to use to uniquely identify this
course
it has the name of the teacher and a
title now you may argue that we can use
the ID to uniquely identify this course
while that's correct
I prefer using some other unique string
or identifier to identify my course
or entities I just do not like to rely
on the auto generated ID fields in any
database at all
finally we have the lessons these are
the individual lessons that belongs to
some course
for example
if we click on the Blazer
webassembly and web API on dotnet 6.
listen you can see it has an identifier
just like the courses it has a title and
it also has an ID
now these lessons here has a belongs to
relationship with the courses which
means each of these lessons belongs to a
certain course
for example if I zoom in on the Blazer
course
as you can see
all these four lessons belongs to the
Blazer shopping cart course
finally there is the enrolled in
relationship
which is between the individual users
and courses
so for example
John W here is enrolled in the Blazer
shopping cart course
now that we are done with our database
we can finally start working with our
API
for that you will need jdk pre-installed
on your computer
now you can download the jdk from
oracle's website I am going to use jdk
17 since that's the latest long term
support release
but you can also go with jdk 20 it's
totally up to you
one more thing for those who are
watching this course on Linux it's
totally fine to use any of the open jdk
builds for example
I myself am using the Microsoft build of
open jdk instead of oracle's official
build
and given the complexity of our API it's
not going to make
any
change or it it will not break anything
whatsoever so feel free to use uh any
open jdk build that you like you will
also need a good ide to make your you
know programming process more fun I'm
going to use IntelliJ IDEA ultimate here
I have a student license so I'm going to
use that but if you want you can also
use the Community Edition to be honest
if you look at the feature comparison
here most of the essentials are
available under the Community Edition we
do not need the HTTP client thing since
we are going to use a third party client
anyway we do not need database tools or
SQL or any of these things for this
project at least
finally
we need to initialize our project
for that we are of course going to use
the spring initializer
now I will leave the link to Spring
initializer down in the description so
once you have navigated to this page we
will make some choices here and we will
generate our project boilerplate
first make sure that you are picking
Maven under project here you can also
use griddle if you have previous
experience with the tool but I am just
going to pick maven the language will
remain Java for the spring boot version
I am going to use 3.1.0 since that's the
latest at the time of recording but if
some other version comes out later on
while you are watching this course feel
free to use that just do not pick any of
the snapshots you can stable release
now under group you will have to type
or you should type some domain in
reverse order for example my own domain
is farhan.dev
so I will just type in Dev Dot
then artifact is just a project name so
I am going to call it spring
boot
neo4j you may call it anything that you
like I will also put a sensible
description like a simple
API powered by
you know
or Che
finally make sure that you are picking
the correct Java version from down here
I am going to pick 17 since that's what
I have installed on my computer but if
you have installed 20 make sure that
you're switching to 20. for packaging
format we will go with jar since that a
lot widely used than wire format so
let's not change that
another most important part adding
dependencies
now this is needless to say that we will
need a number of different dependencies
for our project but
for starters I will just pick spring web
and
the devtools
now you may think that
Why not pick the new 4G dependencies
while we are here well I could have
picked them but one thing that I have
noticed in the past
is that many people face difficulties
while they try to add new dependencies
to a project that they have already
initialized
so I thought why not to start the
project with just the bare bones uh you
know essential dependencies only and
then as we go forward we will keep
adding new dependencies to our project
that way it will represent a much more
realistic you know development workflow
and it will also teach you how you can
search for new dependencies and add them
on the flag
so take a good look at all the choices
you have made and once you are happy
with them click on generate
it will download a little zip file to
your computer
that contains all the project 5.
I'm going to just open up the zip file
using
no Windows Explorer or WinRAR or
whatever you like
copy the project folder
go to a place that where you usually put
your codes in I usually put them in
individual directories so I'm going to
paste it here
and once I have done that I will just
open up my IDE which is
IntelliJ IDEA
I will open up my project
input neo4j okay yes we trust the
project
and once you have opened the project for
first time I would say give it some time
to you know cash all your dependencies
uh read the source files and things like
that so the ID knows about your project
and it can help you along the way
hello everyone
I am your instructor Farhan but I am
from future
now in the next lessons you may see a
little problem with the video in some
cases when I am trying to create a new
class or maybe a new package you may see
that this menu is not showing up now
this is because my recorder was only
recording one window in my computer so
all this sub menus were invisible
so whenever you see me creating a new
package all you have to do is right
click
on your main package go to new and then
package likewise when I am cheating in
new class you have to pick Java class
from here and you can switch between
interfaces and classes right from this
menu
another thing that didn't work in my
previous recording was the code
generation thing
so whenever you are creating a new model
you can use the alt insert key
combination sorry inside the class of
course
let's get rid of the Constructor and you
can use alt insert and you can then
generate a Constructor you can generate
Getters and Setters and equals and hash
code two strings and all those
boilerplate methods so what I did in
those videos is I picked Constructor and
then I just ignored all these properties
since you are trying to create an empty
Constructor and then press ok
so
a good chunk of the course if you see
all these sub menus are invisible just
don't be alarmed it was some problem
with my recorder everything should work
as is in your computer
now back to the past
as you can see IntelliJ IDEA has finally
finished resolving all the dependencies
in my project so I am finally ready to
write some code now before we start
writing Java code I'd like to address
something really important I hope that
you remember back when we are generating
our project we didn't add all the
dependencies to our project because I
wanted to show you how you can manually
add dependencies later on
so this is the time we do that first
open up your pom.xml and find this
dependencies part
inside that
you can see that there are three
dependencies already described
you may recognize the spring boot
starter web and springboard Dev tools
dependencies from a few moments ago when
we added them to our project but there
is also another thing called Spring boot
a startup test now this is for testing
our code and in this course we are not
going to talk about that
now the first dependency that we need to
add to our project is
called
the spring
put a starter
data neo4j and the group ID will be org
Dot springframework.put
now IntelliJ IDEA is being really
generous here and helping us out with
writing the dependencies but I suggest
that you make sure that you are typing
them out correctly because if you make a
typo or write wrong name then you may
end up not getting a dependency or even
worse getting the wrong dependency
now the second dependency
that we need is called the neo4j Java
driver and the group is org.neo4j dot
driver
now whenever you add or remove a
dependency from your palm.xml file you
have to right click on the palm.xml file
find Maven and reload project
depending on how many dependencies you
have added or removed from your project
the resolving process may take a while
but in my case it has finished in a
Flash
now I will close the pom.xml file and
start creating the packages that we will
need
now inside our main package
dave.farhand.springboot neo4j it may be
something else in your case but
inside our main package we will create
four new packages now the first one
will be called
config
then we will create
another package called models
then we will have
the repositories
the services
and our controllers
now these are not the only packages that
we are going to need we will also need
some packages to hold our query results
our data transfer objects our requests
and things like that but we'll work on
them later for now these are the ones
that we need now once you have all the
package ready to go let's create the
model for our first node which in this
case will be the course so let's create
a new Java class
and call it
course
then inside we will Define all the
necessary properties of this class so
the first one is an ID and it has to be
of type long
then we will have private string
identifier which will used uniquely
identify our courses
then private string title
and private extreme teacher
then we will create a Constructor now
you may write the Constructor by hand
but inside IntelliJ you can just press
on alt and then insert to bring up this
nice generate menu
from here you can select Constructor
and for our Constructor we will not
select any of the properties
now for
spring data neo4j this is one of the
requirements that you create an empty
Constructor inside your model classes so
this is what we are going to do
then we will
say alt insert and we will select
Getters and setters
highlight identifier title and teacher
we will not highlight ID
and why you will understand in a bit
click OK and now we have all the Getters
and Setters for our
private properties
now creating a class like this will not
suffice who you will also have to
annotate this class with the node
annotation
This Way Spring boot will know that this
class is actually a new 4G node and has
to be managed by the dependency
injection system
then inside the class we will also
annotate the ID with two separate
annotations the first one has to be the
ID annotation
to let springboot know that this is the
ID for the node
and then we will say generated value
which means we want this value to be
automatically generated and we do not
want to write it by hand
now since this ID is an automatically
generated value we do not need a set of
file and since we are not going to use
these two uniquely identify our course
we are going to use this string
identifier instead we can just get rid
of the getter as well
so now that we have a course class the
next
the next thing to create is a repository
so let's go inside the repositories
package go to new Java class and we will
call this course
Repository
and it has to be an interface by the way
once you have created the interface it
is going to extend
the neo4j repository interface which
comes with our dependency
and this is a generic and inside
we will write the name of the class that
we are working with which is course
and we will also write the data type of
the ID of this course so in our case it
will be learn
now this way of creating a new
repository is nothing unique
to neo4j actually if you have experience
with spring boot in the past and you
have worked with databases like mongodb
or MySQL you may have created interfaces
like this
now let's close our repository and model
and let's go inside our service
we will create another Java class called
course service
and we will have to annotate this class
with the service annotation
then inside this class we will need a
reference to our course repository so
you will say
private final course repository course
repository you can name it anything
and then we will generate a new
Constructor where we will take the
repository now that's it now since we
have annotated this service class
with the service annotation and also the
repository
extends the base neo4j repository did
this will be on automatically injected
into our class
now inside here we will create another
public method we will say public
and it is going to return a list of
courses
get all courses you can name it anything
by the way
then we'll say return course repository
dot find all
that's it
finally we will create a controller by
the way if you think that I'm going to
fast just be patient once I have created
the model repository service and
controller for the course I will explain
the entire workflow or the architecture
of the application what I am planning to
do and what you should do in any of your
spring boot applications
so finally I will create a controller
new Java class and it will be called
course
controller
now I need to annotate this class with
the rest controller annotation
so a springboot knows that this is
actually a rest controller and this is
going to describe a few endpoints
then I will say request mapping this
another annotation and I will describe
the general endpoint
so I'll say slash API slash V1 slash
purchases
slept
now inside this public class I will
create a
private reference to our service class
so I will surprise it
final
course service
or service
then I will generate my Constructor
and I will create my first method which
will be public
and it will return our response entity
yes response entity of type list
course
I'll explain what it is in a bit just
just hold on for a little longer
and I will call My Method course index
you can call it anything this is just
going to list out all the courses in our
application
and then we will say
return
new response entity
and inside here I will call
courseservice Dot get all courses then
comma
HTTP status dot ok
and with a semicolon then I will also
have to annotate this class with a git
mapping call
and this
okay let's let's take a final look at
our application and make sure that the
code is working fine yeah that that
looks okay
now
we have a model
that describes the course node in our
database
and as I have said a few times already
in our database the courses have an ID
which is an auto generated field
we have a string identifier a title and
teacher then we will need
an empty Constructor for all our models
then we have some Getters and Setters to
work with this model we create a
repository interface which in turn
extends the new 4J repository interface
now what is this interface actually to
see what this contains we can press on
the control button and then click on
this Repository
once you are inside the source code you
can see it gives us a few useful methods
and one of them is find all so whenever
I am going to call find all in this
repository it will actually return all
the courses in our database in a list
format as you can see it says list t
there is also find all by ID there is
also find all with assort functionality
so we can sort the courses so this is
what a repository holds there is also a
safe all method but let's ignore that
for now
now since we have a repository we can
used it inside a service you do not want
to use your repositories inside a
controller directly because that's not a
good thing to do you should always
create a service layer that talks to the
repositories and use that service inside
your controller layer always remember
that controller should be responsible
for taking and giving back data they
should not
worry themselves about the underlying
architecture of your database or your
models or anything like that
so in this case we have a service class
that makes a reference to our course
Repository
and we have a single method that gets
all the courses for us
one thing that I'd like to mention here
that you may have seen the auto wired
annotation that comes with the spring
Boot and maybe instead of creating
a Constructor like this I could have
just annotated this field with autoware
but in some cases that's not the best
thing to do now since we have our
service we will go to our controller
that describes a single endpoint which
is API V1 courses
inside this method we are just returning
a new response entity this is one of the
classes that comes with spring Boot and
you can use it to return a response to
the user
and this response entity thing takes two
things
one is body and the other is the status
code now for body we are giving it the
least of the course since it's a
response entity of type list course
and for status code maybe we have
written 200 by by hand but instead of
using some magic number what we are
doing here we are using the value of ok
inside HTTP status this is actually an
enum this enum here actually describes a
lot of other status codes as you can see
it has continued it has switching
protocol processing checkpoint okay
created accepted we are going to use
created very soon no content and a lot
of other things so we are going to make
use of this enumerator a lot in our
application
so
technically our application is ready to
run and give us the list of courses but
we have to make one final adjustment and
that is we have to
let the application know about our
database that we have created earlier
for that we will need another dependency
now the dependency that we need is
called Spring dot EnV
so we'll say
dependency and inside artifact ID we
will write spring
Dot N
and inside group ID
we will say
n e dot all
words s c h w a r c
okay and we will also describe a version
for this dependency
subversion
3.0.2
we'll save the form.xml file and use
this little button here to load the
maven changes let's click that and wait
until the dependencies are being loaded
so as you can see it has turned white
from Red which means the dependencies
have been loaded successfully
next up we will create a very simple EnV
file
inside
SRC main resources
and we will just right click on the
resources folder new and file we will
call it dot EnV now this EnV file will
contain three values the first one is
or uh
URI
the second one is or
user and the third one is aura
password
now as you may have already guessed the
aura URI is a URI to our neo4j server on
the cloud the aura user is the name of
the user or the username and finally the
password is for the password for the
database now the order user is going to
be always new for J
and I will just quickly copy
the URI and password from my new
fourject credentials file
okay so I have copied my URI and
password from my credentials file and
these are going to be different in your
case since your instance is different
from mine
now once you have created this dot EnV
file next up you will need to open the
application.properties file now inside
we are going to reference the three EnV
values we that we have so I will just
say spring Dot
Neo
4J
dot URI
and then
a dollar sign
curly braces and
aura
URI
next up is spring dot Newport
dot Authentication
dot username
again another dollar sign
early braces and aura
user
finally it says spring dot neo4j dot
authentication
dot password it's a dollar sign credit
braces or a password
now why did we do this why we didn't
just put all these values inside our
application.properties class
now the thing is these values that URI
to your instance the user password and
the username are secret values these are
things that you should never put on your
GitHub repository
since the application.properties file is
a part of your application we will not
put our secrets directly into this file
instead we are going to create an EnV
file
and these three variables will be loaded
into our local environment
and then the application properties will
be able to find them using this dollar
sign and curly braces Index this is how
you actually access any of the
environment variables inside your
application
now I would suggest that you also make a
copy of this file
and call it.anv Dot example
then get rid of these values
save the example file
and make sure that your dot EnV file is
being ignored inside your git ignore
file so inside here I will say
dot EnV
and then set dot EnV so this will make
sure that the dot EnV file is not added
to your GitHub repository
instead you will have an example file
that you can use a reference to create a
new enp file
okay so since we have our model
controller suppositories and services in
place
and we also have our EnV file created
our application should be ready to
connect to our database and give us a
list of the courses let's test it out to
do so you will have to click on the play
button
so far it looks like that the
application is running fine
so what we are going to do is we are
going to switch to an HTTP client called
insomnia and we will test out our
application by sending a request to it
now inside insomnia the first thing that
you should do is create a new folder
because we want to keep our requests
organized now I will call it spring
boot neo4j
and I will move or just just let's get
rid of this request now inside this
folder I will create a new HTTP request
this is going to be a get request of
course
and this is going to
http
localhost
8080 slash API slash V1 slash courses I
hope that you remember
and let's also rename this to
get all courses or something like that
okay
it really doesn't matter to Grants
now let's send a request
yeah and looks like we have our list of
courses as you can see we had four
courses in our database and all of those
are being taught by Gavin long and the
list contains all of 10 and we also have
a 200 okay status quo I hope you
remembered that we had added that little
status HTTP status dot OK at the end so
that's why you are getting the nice 200
okay response here so congratulations on
creating your first API endpoint in this
application
next up we are going to work on the
lessons and we will implement the
relationship between the lessons and the
courses and we'll also make sure that we
can
see the details of this individual
courses along with the list of the
lessons
so I am back at IntelliJ IDEA once again
and now we are going to start working on
another endpoint for our application
so let's go back to controllers now the
next endpoint that I want to work on is
an endpoint that's going to return the
details of a single course
so if I go back to insomnia let's make a
copy of this request
okay
single course
and we will just pick an identifier from
all courses request
we will put it inside the single request
and we want to make something like this
now I actually like to start working
from the lowest level of our application
which in our case are the repositories
so I will go back to course Repository
and inside we are finally going to
create a custom method
now this custom method will return an
optional course
and we will call this method find
course by
identifier
and then
we'll take a string identifier
now the nice thing about these neo4j
repositories is the fact that they are
really smart
so just by the name of this method find
course by identifier
spring boot will know that we are trying
to find a course by using identifier
property
and we will also need to pass the
identifier by string now if I remove
this part and I write it again I will
say find
and as you can see IntelliJ IDEA
actually recommends me that
find course buy so you can sense that
maybe you are trying to find a course by
some parameter so I'm going to pick find
course by and then now it started to
suggest me the possible property names
and from this list I am going to pick
identifier
and inside of course we are going to
pass the identifier let's say string
identifier
okay now we have the repository method
we will go back to our service
which is the one step higher level of a
repository and we will say
public course
and we will call it get
course
by identifier
and we will take
the identifier as and string
now inside the method we will say return
course repository Dot
find course by identifier identifier
now I hope that you remember that the
method actually returns an optional type
and we are trying to return a course
object from this method so what we are
going to do
in the second line we will say
R else true so if you do not find this
course or if you do not find a course by
this identifier
true
site there will create a new Lambda and
we will send new
response
status exception
and we'll say HTTP status quote
Dot
value of
so what we are saying is first use the
find course by identifier method inside
the course repository and try to find a
course by this identifier the identifier
that I have passed
and in case you do not find a course
using this identifier please throw a 404
not found response exception status
that's what we are doing
let's close this service
and inside our controller
we will create a new get mapping
public
spawns entity
of type course
and we can call it
course details
it has to be a get mapping
and it will
give us an identifier so we are will get
the identifier from here
and inside course details I will set
path variable
which means we are going to get a
variable from the path
and it will be string
identifier
yeah that's it you can call it anything
else if you want
now inside the method what we are going
to do is we will say return or or let's
just create a course
equals
or service dot get course by identifier
we will pass our identifier right here
and then we'll return
a new response entity
and we are going to say the course is
the body and HTTP status dot okay
okay yeah
so that's it what we are doing here is
we are getting an identifier in our path
we are passing that identifier to our
service layer that service layer in turn
will call our repository and get us the
course that we are looking for
now essentially this should work so
let's try out let's rerun our
application
go back to insomnia and let's execute
the git method that we created a bit
earlier that's it send
so as you can see it actually Returns
the course that we are looking for
and if we try to look for a course that
doesn't exist for example if I add some
garbage here
as you can see we are getting a 404
status now we are also getting a trace
with it uh we may
configure our exceptional responses
later on but for now we will just leave
it like that
let's get rid of the garbage let's send
once again and yes we are getting
the course details now the thing is
the response in the course detailed
request and the course list request is
pretty much the same
I think it would be nice if we could get
the list of the lessons that belongs to
this course inside
this details response right let's do
that let's finally start working on our
lessons
so I'll come back to intelligent
I will create a new model
new
Java class and it's going to be called
lesson
this is going to be a node just like
before
it will have
a long ID
is going to be the ID and also a
generated value
uh okay so I will have to import the uh
I think there's something wrong wait 80.
yeah ID sorry it it didn't get imported
first yeah
next we will say private stream title
and private string identifier so these
are the three properties that we need
next up we will generate our empty
Constructor
and our Getters and setters
yes now before we try to implement our
relationship between the lesson and
courses let's go back to our database
and have a look at how it was mapped
if we focus on a single Corsair as you
can see this course has four lessons
and each of these lessons has a belongs
to relationship with the course
now from the point of view of a single
lesson it has an outgoing relationship
of type belongs to with its parent
course
and from the point of view of the course
it has an incoming relationship of type
belongs to with the lesson
now with that information we can
actually Implement these relationships
in our models
now back in our code we will open the
source code for the course model
and we will describe a new property
private
list
list of lesson
called lessons
plus new error list
now this list here is going to be a
relationship this is another annotation
that comes with
the dependency that we have used
and
the type of the relationship is belongs
to like we just saw in our database
and the direction
from the point of view of the course
it's an incoming Direction
or an incoming relationship so the type
of the relationship is belongs to in the
direction is relationship dot Direction
dot income
now we will need a getter
we do not need a Setter since we are not
going to set this relationship manually
we just need a getter
now since we have implemented the
relationship we have implemented the
getter it should work let's rerun the
application
come back to insomnia
make the request once again
and as you can see now the course comes
back with a list of the lessons as you
can see these Blazer shopping cart of
course as four lessons
now this is all nice and cool but there
is a simple problem
so if I go back to the get all courses
and make a request
as you can see all the courses are
coming back with the lessons
now depending on what you want from your
application this may be something that
you expect or you do not expect for
example
in some places in my application I may
not want the list of the lessons at all
because whenever a course is coming back
with the list of lessons it's actually
querying for all these lessons
so if I do not use the lessons these did
that entire query time that that that
time my server is working is going to
waste
unfortunately there is no way that I
know of to leave out a relationship from
a query
so if you describe a relationship like
that
you cannot actually lazy load it every
time you will query for the courses you
will also get the relationship back
now this is something that's not that
hard to solve actually we can write
custom Cipher queries to query for the
lessons when they are needed
and leave them out when we don't
to do that first let's get rid of the
relationships from the model
also remove this because we are not
going to use them
now at this moment in our code base the
courses and lessons are totally
unrelated to each other
but we have to implement some sort of
relationships between them
now my idea is that we can have them
unrelated in our code base but what we
can do is we can actually create another
Repository
it will be another interface
let's call it lesson Repository
it extends
the neo4j Repository
the object will be lesson
and the ID will be long
and inside this repository we will
Implement another function that is list
lesson this is going to be the return
type
find
lessons
by
course identifier
and we'll get the identifier as a string
okay now we have a method that is going
to find a bunch of lessons using a
course identifier now the course
identifier part is not a property of
lesson so we cannot have and
automatically build method like this
instead what we will do is we will write
a very simple Cipher query
so we'll say query
and inside let's begin
we'll send match
and inside a set of parentheses I will
say colon course
so we are looking for all the nodes of
type course
inside I will say identifier
identifier
so we are looking for a course node that
has the same identifier as we have
passed to this method
now
once we have found this course we will
need to get
and incoming relationship
are of type belongs to
and the related node should be
lessons lesson
and finally we have to return
the lessons
let me explain what we are doing here
first we are trying to find a course
node that has the same identifier as the
one we have passed to this method
then we are looking for all the lessons
that are related to this course
using an incoming belongs to
relationship
now once we have found all the lessons
we are putting them inside another
variable called lessons and finally we
are returning the lessons
in fact we can we can get rid of this R
variable here since that's not being
used anywhere so the only
piece of variable that we need is this
one here
once again we are finding a course by
the identifier that we have then we are
looking for all the lessons that has an
incoming relationship with this course
of type belongs to
then we are putting those lessons inside
the lessons variable and returning them
to the user so this is the query that we
have
now if everything goes fine it should
return a list of the lessons
okay the repository is all set let's
create a service
lesson service
this is going to be a service class
and inside the class we want a private
final
lesson repository lesson Repository
we will have our Constructor
and we will have
public
person list of lesson
the name of the method should be get all
lessons
by course
identifier
we will get a string identifier
and then inside the method we will say
lesson repository dot find lessons by
course identifier and we will say
identify
that's it and we can just return this
directly or return this directly
and yeah that's it that that's all you
need in the lesson service
then
inside the controllers as you can see
right now we are returning a course
now this is all right but
what would be better is if we return a
dto or a data transfer object
so I'll just rename my
config package to objects because we are
not going to use the config right now
refactor
and we will create a new class
called course
dto
so this is a plain Java class
inside I'll subscribe it string
identifier because I want the identifier
for the course
I want private string
and title
I want the title for the course
private string
teacher
and
private list
list of lesson called lessons equals New
Era list
excellent
oh it looks like we have to import the
lesson class
yes
finally we will have our Constructor
an empty Constructor for that because we
are going to insert all these values
later on
or you know what we can get all this
like this
Constructor identifier yes let's let's
take these three and leave out the
lessons because we are going to fill it
up later
next we want to create some Getters uh
we need Getters for everything and we'll
need a Setter for the lesson
yes so that's that's all we need for the
moment
now let's go back to the course
controller inside this method instead of
returning a course I will select course
tto
and I have the course here
then I I will create course tto
response course another object equals to
new course tto
first I will need course dot get
identifier
next I need the title so of course
dot get title comma finally
ports
dot get
teacher yeah
those are the three
and then I will say response course Dot
set lessons
and now we need to bring in our private
final
lesson service lesson service here
we need to add lesson service lesson
service
and inside
our Constructor and set this
dot lesson service equals less service
yeah so we have
that
initialized
this looks fine to me
now inside response course dot
setlessons I'll sell lesson service Dot
get all Distance by course identifier
and course dot get identifier so I will
get all the lessons inside this course
finally in the return statement instead
of course I will just say response
course
now technically if we have written
everything correctly this should give us
the list of lessons along with the other
course details
so I'll just restart my application
it has been restarted let's go back to
insomnia
send a request for a single course
and as it looks like we are still
getting the list of the lessons but if I
go back to get all courses
as you can see now there are no lessons
at all so inside single course I can get
the lessons because I want them to be
there
and inside get on courses I do not need
them so I don't have them at all
I hope you have understood how you can
write a simple custom Cipher query
inside Java and this is going to be
really helpful now creating this course
dto class and later on we are going to
also create query
results class
this all things may seem like a lot of
work to you but to be honest once you
have everything set up you have the code
ready to go you will see how easy it is
to make changes because
uh you are making sure that you are
going you are abiding by the separation
of concerns and things like that
so okay we have done that now one thing
that I'd like to say that the way the
front end of our application has been
created we actually need the list of
lessons in the list of courses as well
so
what I am going to do is I am going to
make some changes to it
this uh list or the
course index method and make sure that
we are getting the list of lessons there
as well
so I will change it to a course tto
and yes the return hold return statement
won't work anymore
so I will copy this
I'll send list
course
courses
ah sorry
and I'm getting a list of all the
courses in our database
then
what I'm going to do is I am going to
create another list of the course tto
type
and this will be the response courses
equals
I will say
courses dot stream so I am going to use
the stream API of java
then I will call the map
now inside map
I will say course
foreign
and here I will create a new core Studio
or Studio response course
equals to
I can actually copy this entire line
yes that I can also copy this line
read it after this yes response course
dot lesson.service so now I have a new
course tto
and I need to return this so I'll say
return
sponse course
and finally
Dot
collect
character stop to list
so what I am doing here I am getting the
list of courses from my database without
the lessons
then I am mapping through that list
accessing each course inside that list
of courses
I am treating a new dto object I am
getting all the lessons for that course
and setting that inside my dto object
and finally I am returning that response
course from inside
the standup function
and once I have returned that I am
creating a new list and adding that new
response course to that list so this is
how it goes finally inside response
entity I will just replace this part
with
response courses
http status okay
let's save our code and let's restart
and see if it works fine or not
let's go back to insomnia
make a request for all the courses
and as you can see all the lessons are
back in the course class
so this far we have finally implemented
the courses we have implemented the
lessons we have written some custom
Cipher query
so I think you have done a lot of work
already to be honest
now next up we are going to implement uh
the user model we will introduce an
authentication system to this
application so that users can log in
and once that done we can finally work
on the course enrollments
so let's continue working on it
now that we have finished implementing
the courses and lessons it's time to
finally work on the user now before you
start writing our code for the user
related functionalities we will need to
add
a new dependency
so open up your pom.xml file
then right after spring dot EnV add a
new dependency
now the name of this dependency will be
spring
boot
starter
security
and its group ID will be simply org dot
spring
framework
dot boot like all the other starter
packages in fact let's do one thing
let's cut this chunk of code from here
and put it right after the starter data
neo4j that way we will have all our
starter packs in a in a line and then we
will have the other dependencies
so once you have added this dependency
to your project just
hit this load Maven changes button
okay it looks like the dependency has
been resolved
now
let's try to restart our application
and you should see something like this
using generated security password the
generated password is for development
use only and things like that
so this means that Spring Security is
actually working now to test it out we
can go back to insomnia
we can send one of our old requests
and you will see that it says 401
unauthorized which means that the spring
security system is stopping us from
accessing this endpoint now this is
totally normal by default Spring
Security
stops all the requests to the server but
you can use an username and password to
get access to the data you want now for
that let's go back to our IDE look for
your
application.properties file inside SRC
Main and resources
now after the three lines that we added
before we will have to add two more
lines these are spring Dot security
dot user dot name
and I'll set it to Farhan
spring.security.user Dot
password equals to password
now let's go back to insomnia
here you can see there is the auth menu
right besides body so I will go inside
auth I will click on this arrow and pick
basic auth
inside here I will add the username
Farhan and password is
password then I will send the request
okay it looks like we forgot to restart
our application
so let's do that
now insomnia
sent request
and it worked out just fine
but I know what you are thinking this is
not the right way to authenticate any
request we want to use the users in our
database right
don't worry we are going to do that but
before I just wanted to show you how you
can
make your request go through the Spring
Security
gate
now let's disable the Authentication
okay
let's go back to our IDE and start
working on a proper authentication
system first let's remove these two
values
close the properties stop our
application and minimize the timing
now we will start by creating a new
model
named user
now unlike the models that we have
worked on before the user is going to
implement an interface so we will write
implements
user
details
now this interface is actually part of
the Security package that we just added
and it describes a few
methods and properties that makes this
model usable for our authentication
system
so we can hover over it
and it says Implement methods we'll
click that
and it it shows us a bunch of methods we
will say okay
and now we have a lot of overrides let's
just close this sidebar for more space
okay so these are the methods that we
want to implement
so let's start with uh
get password and get username because
those are the easiest one
we will say private
a string username
private
string password
then inside get password we will return
password
and inside username we will return
username
excellent now those two have been taken
care of next we will add
the roles so you would say private
string
roles I hope that you remember from our
database view from before that every
single users has a bunch of roles so
this is what we are going to do here
now once you have added the roles
we want to implement the get authorities
method which is this one
now this is sort of and special kind of
method that actually returns all the
authorities or roles for this user
now you may have seen that I had added a
role user value to our
users in our database but you can have
something like role admin
role teacher and so on you can also have
role admin comma role teacher
role
moderator and so on but for now we are
dealing with a single role
now this method here it returns a
collection and that extends the granted
Authority interface
so what we need to do is we will say
return we need the arrays class from
java.util and then we will say dot
stream
inside the stream method we need our
roles so the roles that we have defined
here will say roles
Dot
split
and we want to split it by a comma
because remember we can have roles like
this
roll
admin
role
teacher
so we want to split it using this comma
after splitting let's come to the next
line and we will say map
we will say simple
granted Authority which is a class and
we will add new
at the end
and Dot to list
see and we are returning this list so
what we are doing here we are getting
the value of the roles string from this
user
we are splitting the string using the
commas so just in case you decide to add
multiple roles to this user
and then we are mapping through that new
you know splitted string and creating
new simple granted authorities using the
string value that we get from our map
call
finally once we have multiple or a
single simple granted Authority instance
we are adding them to a list and
returning that list from this method so
since lists are part of collections
these checks out
now if you are confused about this
method I would suggest that you do some
more study on how Spring Security works
and how you can Implement multiple roles
for users so that's a bit out of the
scope of this course so this is what we
have to do now
next up let's go inside is account
non-expired we want to return true here
then is account non-locked yes we want
to return true is credentials
non-expired true
and also is the account enabled yes true
so that's it we have successfully
implemented the user details uh
interface but other than these three we
also need
an ID
and we need a private string
name for the user
unlike the other models this ID is going
to be an ID and it is going to be a
generated value
and we will need a getter and Setter for
our name
so
let's come at the end of all these
overrides
or maybe
maybe here let's come to this place
and we'll say alt insert we will
generate a getter
for our ID
no I mean our name
we will also need a Setter for our name
there you go
now in the case of this user model we
will actually use our ID field so we
will also add a getter for that
and since we are going to create new
users we will also need Setters for our
username and password and roles
so let's scroll down
and come to get password and I will come
after it and insert
a Setter
for our password
there we have it
next after the get username I will
insert a Setter for our username
and finally we do not have a get roles
method but we have this one so I will
just come after this
and I will input a Setter
for our rows
there you go
it looks like the model is ready to be
used
and you know what let's just generate a
getter for our roles as well because
even though we have this get authorities
method we may also need a plain old
getter for our rolls string so let's
just add the getter
and it looks like everything has been
set up finally uh I I would just like to
check the channel you know once again to
see if we have anything left
yeah we have left ID Setter but we are
not going to need that
so once you are done with that let's
just close this
and we will now create a new package
called
config
next up let's create a new Repository
so I will right click on the
repositories package create a new Java
class it has to be an interface and name
it user Repository
uh like the other repositories I want to
extend uh neo4j repository and that's
all we need for now we will come back to
this because we will add two more custom
queries uh to this repository but those
are not needed at the moment
finally we will go inside service and we
are going to create an special service
for our authentication system
so you will create a new class called
Neo
user details service you may call it
something else like neo4j user details
service the thing is this is going to be
an user Detail Service that we will in
turn use with Spring Security
so we have this class
and it's going to implement another
interface called user details service
and just like the model we will
implement the methods there is only one
method load user by username
and that's pretty much it
so as you can see from the name of this
method these can return a user using its
username so for that we will go back to
our user Repository
we will create
a method that returns an optional user
and we will call it find
user sorry I have made a mistake we will
have to delete the name of the model as
well as the type of ID we are using
all right now we can say find user by
username
we will receive the username as and
string
this is very simple method and that's
all we need
now inside our new user details service
I will explain why we need this class in
a bit but for now just write the class
along with me
so I will create a private
final
user repository user Repository
then I will have a Constructor
there you go
and then as you can see this method here
Returns the type user details this is
one of the interfaces that comes with
the Spring Security framework
so instead of returning null
what we are going to do is return
sorry user Repository
dot or let's come to the next line find
user by username we'll pass the username
that we have here
and then on the third line we will say
or else throw
and inside the method we will create a
new Lambda
new
username not found exception
and we will pass a message
username not
found
then you can just
add the username to the message yeah so
that's what we have so as you can see
the user details service interface
implements a method called load user by
username so what we are doing here we
are using our repository instance and we
are calling the find user by username
method now it returns an optional user
so if we have the user then we will
return it and if we do not have the user
then we will throw a new username not
found exception and we have to throw
this exception because uh by the
definition of this interface this method
has to throw a username not found
exception in cases where the username is
not found
so that's all we need here
now finally we are going to write the
big chunk of authentication code that we
will need to use our database instead of
some preset user
so go inside project I will collapse
everything then go inside
source main Java
and as you can see I have a package
called config so I will right click and
create a new class
called security config
by the way the service class that we
created has to be annotated with the
service annotation yeah
that's all the service classes have been
annotated okay so inside the security
config class we have to annotate it with
configuration
then enable
web
security
okay then inside the class
we will create a private final
Neo user details service
we will have a Constructor
and then we are going to create a bean
and that b is of type security
filter
chain
new security filter chain
it will receive HTTP security
this one
we will call it HTTP security and these
throws
an exception
okay let's annotate with the bean
annotation so that
neo4j will handle the task of
instantiating this class and everything
now inside this method we will create a
new security filter chain once we have
finished working on it you will
understand what it actually does so
we'll say return
HTTP security this one
then dot session management
inside will say session
get a new Lambda
session Dot
session
creation policy
then session creation policy dot
stateless because
since we are creating an API the
authentication has to be stateless
then we are going to disable csrf
protection because
we don't need that
for that we will use abstract
http
configurer yes this one
and noticeable
okay then on the next line we will say
course because we are going to customize
our course
customizer
dot with defaults so course will be
configured with the default settings
finally we'll say authorize HTTP
requests
inside we'll say auth
and auth
Dot
it will say request matches yes
and inside the request matches we will
say
API
slash V1
slash auth
slash me
okay
let's leave it to that for now we will
add more routes to it later so I'll say
dot authenticated
and Dot
any request
Dot permit off
finally
we will finish this by saying user
details service
Neo user details service
dot HTTP basic
customizer dot with defaults
and
dot build
Ah that's a lot of code right so let us
take a look and try to understand what's
happening here so
by default the Spring Security framework
uses a security filter chain that blocks
any request to your server
you will have to authenticate for every
single request to the server and we do
not want that
also in the default security filter
chain it uses your
application.properties file or a
randomly generated user as an
authenticatorable user we also do not
want that we want to use the users in
our database
so for that we will need to create a new
security filter chain that will
essentially Define how we want to secure
our application
so inside this pane I hope you
understand what beans are beans are just
Java classes that are managed to buy the
spring boot framework so we are creating
a new Bean
that is of type security filter chain
and it throws an exception
okay so inside this bin we are saying
return HTTP security which is of type
HTTP security
this is
one of the classes that comes with the
Spring Security framework
and the first thing that we are doing is
we are making the session stateless I
know this is a long line but all this
does is it makes the sessions stateless
so we do not hold any session data
whatsoever
then we are disabling the csrf
Securities because since it is an API
and we essentially do not have any web
interfaces within this particular
application or service we can
successfully disable the csrf protection
then we are configuring course so in an
application where there is no spring
boot security framework you have to
customize your cost settings somewhere
else but since we are using spring boot
security this framework is going to
intercept the request first and then it
will pass it to the application or other
configurers so we have to configure the
course right in the security filter
chain configuration thing
so right now we are
customizing the cost settings with the
default ones but we are going to change
it very soon
then we are saying authorize HTTP
request so this is the method where we
will Define which routes has to be
protected by our application and which
routes do not need to be protected so
inside we have an auth object and we are
using the request matches method to say
that hey Spring boot security you have
to protect any request
to this particular endpoint we haven't
created this endpoint here and you only
need to stop any request coming to this
endpoint and all the other requesters
any requests
just permit them to connect
so
when we get a request in this particular
endpoint it needs to be authenticated
any other request
should be permitted
now next up we will actually configure
our course configurations so we will say
pause Pawn figure
or con course configuration sources this
one we want this one
and then we will say course
configuration Source we will start the
method and we'll annotate with a beam
now inside this bin we will say
course configuration
course configurations equals to new
Parts configuration so we are creating a
new course configuration
then we are going to
change things in this configuration so
we will say course configuration Dot
set allowed
Origins
so which Origins are we allowing so I'll
just say
array let's check what it takes so it
looks like
it takes a list of strings so I will say
array
dot as list arrays.list
and I will create a string http
localhost
3000.
and also just in case http
127.0.0.1 which is localhost as well
three thousand so I have been made aware
by Gavin long that the react application
that he will be working on
will run on localhost 3000 or 127001
Port 3000 so what I have done
I have allowed these two Origins to
connect to my to my application
now this is one way of doing things to
be honest these two values these should
be resided inside our DOT EnV file but I
am not going to do that since I have
shown you how to use a DOT Envy file I
will just add a to-do here
which says
make sure that
the origin list comes
from and in
environment five so I would suggest that
the viewers or you essentially take this
as a challenge and implement this part
using an EnV file put your code on
GitHub and share the link in the comment
section I will take my time to go
through every single code shared in the
comment section and I will make sure
that everything is right so this is one
of the challenges I will add that as a
to-do and you can actually click on this
button here to do and you can see
what challenges I have set
so that's one challenge
then the second one is course
configuration dot set
allowed methods and what methods are we
allowing
areas dot as list this also takes a list
so
this is how you are going to do kth and
we will do Post
we will do patch
then put
delete
options
and
these are all owed methods then we'll
say course configuration dot set allow
credentials yes this one and with set
two
nice
then we will say course configuration
dot set allowed
headers
and arrays
dot as list
authorization
request
type
content
type so these are the three headers that
we want to allow
finally we'll say configuration
dot set exposed headers
and it will be called arrays.list
inside here we will say
X
get
header
and lastly we will have course
configuration dot set max age
we will let's say let's do it 360 3600l
so L for long next less let's just
create an URL based course configuration
source so we'll say
URL paste course configuration source
and URL based on course configuration
Source equals to new
URL based course configuration search
here try saying that 10 times faster
right URL based course configuration
Source yeah I can do that
and we will say URL based course
configuration Source yes
dot register course configuration
and we want to apply these configuration
to all the routes in our application so
that's what this pattern means so this
is the root and anything that comes
after that
comma and course configuration yeah
nice finally we have to return
our URL based course configuration
source okay so now we have our course
configured one last thing that we have
to configure is actually a password
encoder so I believe you remember when I
showed you our database architecture
that we are saving the password for the
users
as Big Crypt encrypted hashes we are not
saving plain text passwords because you
should never do that
so we will need to let the spring boot
security know what encoder we are using
so to do that I will say password
encoder
password encoder
this is another Bean
I will annotate this one with pin
and then inside the method I will say
return
new be creeped password encoder
and end it there
so yes we have done most of the things
oh by the way I think I have missed
these three lines so what we are saying
here
is we need to let the security filter
chain know which user details service
are we going to use and in our case we
have a custom user details service which
is the new user details service and what
we have inside this class
we have implemented a single method that
helps us to use or look for the user so
every time some user tries to log into
our application the Spring Security
filter chain will use this detailed
service look for the user and then
check the password against the hash that
we have saved in our database using this
password encoder and if it matches it
will let the request pass through and if
it doesn't it will throw a username not
found exception
so finally we are going to use an HTTP
basic authentication I know this is
pretty insecure but for the scope of
this project or this application this is
totally fine I could have implemented a
a more sophisticated JWT based
authentication but that will take a lot
more time and a lot more code so I want
to focus more on the on the neo4j and
the spring boot connectivity rather than
the authentication and security part of
the application so this is what we are
going for
so now that we have configured our
security thing let's let's just go ahead
and create this
um
end point so we will go to Project
and we will create a new controller
and it will be called user controller
let's annotate this one as
our rest controller and request mapping
to
apis slash
V1 slash Alt
inside we'll have a single method for
now
which will be
public
logged in user
and
we will create an end point which will
be a get mapping
and it will be called me
finally
inside this logged in user we have to
Define our return type which will be
string for now
and we will get something called the
principle I I will explain what
principle is and we will return
principal dot get name
so okay let's make sure that this
endpoint is right so let's go back to
our config
API V1 auth me
so everything checks out
hmm
okay then let's start our application
and try to log in using one of the users
in our database
right now we are inside our neo4j
dashboard and we can see all the users
in our database so I am going to just
select John price and the username is
just price
now the password for all these users
such as Mirza Mikhail or MacMillan the
password is actually password I have
already encoded the password using Big
Crypt and saved the hash
so I will just copy the username of John
price price and let's go back to our
insomnia
then right now if I make a request
without any Authentication
it should work because the single course
and get all courses endpoints have not
been protected I hope that you
remembered that the only endpoint that
is protected right now is the me and
point so I'll create a new HTTP request
I will call this me
HTTP
localhost 8080
API slash P1 slash
auth slash me
and if I send a request as you can see I
am getting 401 unauthorized but if I go
inside auth select basic auth and as the
username I will say price
price and for password I will save
password let's see if it works or not
so as you can see this time we are
getting 200 so what's happening here
let's go back to our code and let me
explain it to you
now right now we have a single endpoint
called slash API V1 auth me and
according to our security configuration
this is one of the protected route and
we have to be authenticated to hit this
route
so inside this method we are getting a
principal object and this principal
object
usually contains information about what
user is authenticated right now so once
you send in your username and password
our security config will intercept that
and pass that to the user Detail Service
the user details service in turn will
look for an user using the username that
we have got from the user and if it
finds the username it will give it back
otherwise it will throw a username not
found exception
once the filter chain has found an user
it will get the password from that user
and
check its hash against the password
submitted by the user using this
password encoder
and you may ask how does the filter
chain gets the password well if I go
back to models user and you will see
we have a getter for the password get
password and this is a part of
the user details interface so that's how
it gets the password hash
and if the user is giving the right
username and password he will pass
otherwise he will not pass so that's how
this entire authentication system works
and if you have done anything right you
should be able to authenticate new users
to your application
now that we have our user we can finally
begin working on the enrollment part so
if user can actually look at our courses
and enroll in the ones that they like so
that's what we are going to do now
now that our users can log into our
system we want to create a way for them
to register in our system so we have a
way to log in now we need a way to
register
so before we start writing the code for
registering the user I would like to
create a few packages and classes
now the first one
is a package called requests
and inside here I will create a new Java
class called
create user request
now I will explain what it will do but
just follow along for now
then inside this class we will say
private string name
private stream username
private string password
private string rows so everything that
the user model has except the ID field
next up we will create a Constructor and
this time we will pick all of them
and after that I will just create some
Getters and setters
okay the request class is ready let's
close that
next what we need is a user dto object
so user dto
and this one is going to be really
simple
private
stream name
private string username
private string
rolls we do not want to return the
password in our responses so we will
just leave that out
next we want to create the Constructor
and the Getters and setters
there you go we have a user dto now
next we need to create a service
called
user service
user
service
and this one has to be annotated as a
new service
for sure
then we will need a private user
repository user repository let's let's
make it final
and then we will have
private final
password encoder password encoder
because we want to encode our user's
password
then I will have my Constructor
and a function
public
and this is going to return a user
create user
and this will take
a create user request not any request
but create user request
and create a new user
so I will say user
user equals to new user
then I will say user dot set name
request dot get name
and I hope you remembered that we just
implemented this get name method inside
the create user class so that's why we
can use that
then user dot set
username
request dot get username nice
user dot set roles
request dot get roles
user dot set password and this is where
the encoder will come in and I will say
password encoder dot in code
inside there I will say request dot get
password so this will take what the
password is that we got from the user
and then encode it and set it as the
user's password
finally we will say user repository dot
save
user the safe method comes with all the
repositories and we will return the user
that's it we have our service method
ready to go
let's go to the controller now
and here
I will say
probably
and then response entity
of type user dto
sign up
and this will take
a request body and map that to create
user request
we'll call it request
and let's go inside the method and I
will say
oh I will also need
a reference to our private final user
service
user service
and I need my Constructor
then I can say
user service dot create user and I can
just pass the request to it
and it returns a user
then I will create a user dto response
user equals to
new user dto now first I need the name
so user dot get name
then user dot get username and user dot
get rules that's all I need
then I can just return a new response
entity
and the body will be the response user
and
the status will be created because we
have just created a new user
so yeah that's all we need to sign up a
new user and this is really easy to do
uh I will have to create a post mapping
or
register
yeah that's all we need now we can go
back to insomnia and check if this works
so I'll just start my application
then I will switch to insomnia
and I will create a new request Alt
register
okay this will have a body
first we need a name
so I will do Farhan
Singh children
comma I need an username
Farhan
then I need a password
and I will need a roots
string so it will be rule
User make sure your
writing the role like this
and then I'll send the request to http
localhost API slash V1 slash auth slash
register
that's it I believe
okay let's change it to post
and we do not need any authentication
for this and let's hit send
so looks like a new user has been
registered it says 201 and the username
is Farhan now there are two ways to
verify if the registration has gone
through correctly or not first I can go
to my me request
I can go to basic and instead of price I
can save Farhan and the password is
password
I'll say send
and it looks like it gives me back
Farhan which means the user has been
registered to database but still if we
quickly switch to our database dashboard
then
click on user once again
it got me back all the users and as you
can see Farhan hasin show 3 is right
here but right now Farhan or me I am not
enrolled in any of the courses so next
we are going to work with the enrollment
process and we are make we are going to
make sure that all the users can
actually enroll in a class but before
that I would like to give another
challenge for you so if I go back to the
user surface as you can see right now I
am not checking if this username has
been already registered or not
so I will leave it to you
so that you can figure out how to check
if a thing exists on the database using
stream boot data or a spring data
repositories and make a decision on that
so I will add another to do and I will
say
makes sure
that these
username does
cyst
and let's just cut that from here and I
will put that over the username so this
is another tutu that I am leaving out
for you I will look forward to any
submission in in the comment section and
I will actually let you know if anything
is wrong with the code
so let's close that
and start working on our enrollment
process
now before I write anything in my
services or in my controllers I would
like to make sure that we have all the
necessary queries in our repositories
for example in order to enroll a user in
a new course we will have to create a
new relationship between the user and
the course
so like I showed you before you can
actually do that through the models but
in this case I am going to create a
custom query that will have a custom
query result and you can use that to
create a new enrollment relationship
so for that
I will go to my repositories and then
user repositories
and I will write two methods here the
first one is going to be a Boolean
and it will be called find enrollment
status
so you can use this method to check
whether a user is already enrolled in a
course or not
now I'll take a string
username and I will also take a string
identifier which is the course
identifier in our case
so we are going to write a custom query
just like we did before
and it will go something like match
user user
or this has to be a string of course
comma
there will be a course course
and then fire
user dot username
equals dollar sign username so this
variable right here
and
user sorry course dot identity fire
equals dollar sign identify right here
this variable so what we are doing is we
are querying for a user
that has the same username as we have
passed to this method
and then we are looking for a course
that has the same identifier as we have
passed in this method and we are saving
the user in a variable called user and
the course in a variable called course
next we want to give a space and then
enter so that we can begin on next line
and then we'll say return
exists
we will say
user
enrolled in
yeah that's pretty much it so what we
are doing is we are looking for a user
and course against the username and
identifier that we have and then we are
checking if there is any outgoing
relationship from the user with the
course of type enrolled in so I believe
you remember that back when we are
designing our database we had a
relationship called enrolled in and it
was the outgoing relationship from the
point of view of the user and an
incoming relationship from the point of
view of the course
so there we go we can use it use this
method to check whether a user is
already enrolled in a course next up we
want to create a query that we can use
to create a new enrollment now before we
do that we need another class
so you create a new package
query
results
and inside that we will create a new
class
called
course enroll
ment
query request
or query results sorry
pretty result now this is a very simple
class we will say private
user user private course
and we need to import these classes
obviously
uh yes
okay we have both the classes then we
will have
and
empty Constructor
like that
and we will have some getter sensors so
alt insert
getter answer both of this
so there you go we have a course
enrollment query result object
now if I come back
and I create a new method
and this is going to return our course
enrollment query result
I would call it create
enrollment
relation
ship basically you want to be explicit
with your names
and I will need a username
also I will need an identifier
now the first bit of this query is
identical to this one so what I am going
to do is I will copy this entire match
part
come inside this method and it's a query
put it in space and then enter now on
the next line I would like to say create
user in fact you can just copy this this
part here
so we are going to
we are going to create
a new outgoing relationship from the
user to the course of type enrolled in
then finally you would like to return
the user
and the course
now as you can see this query returns a
really complex data it returns an user
object and it also returns a course
object so like other custom queries like
this one we cannot just say that these
returns are Boolean type
instead we had to create our own custom
class that has an user object and a
course object and use that as the result
of this query so this is how you can map
complex queries to custom made classes
okay so our user repository is now ready
to go I believe we can enroll our users
to classes now
but we cannot just put the code for
course enrollment inside the user
service or user controller or the course
controller at all instead what we are
going to do is we will create a new
service called
course enrollment
service
and it will be a class
a service class
and inside there we will have a few
methods
now the first method that we have
but before that we will need a private
final
course Repository
course repository and private final
user repository user repository now this
service can access both repositories
because we are going to work with both
courses and enrollment
but if we had to put this code inside
the core service then we would need to
unnecessarily refer to the user
repository inside the course core
service that doesn't
feel good at all that's why we have a
separate service for you know creating
the enrollments
so inside we will have a Constructor
and we will have a few methods
now the first method would be public
Boolean
get enrollment
status
and for that we will need a username
and course identifier
then inside the method
we will just say return
course repository Dot
check uh sorry
user Repository
Dot
find enrollment status and we will pass
it the username and the course
identifier so this way we can use the
this method to check if a given username
is enrolled in a course or not
now the next thing we need is
public and this is going to return a
course enrollment query result
and it will be called enroll in
and it will also need a username
and course identifier
okay we will return
user Repository
Dot
create enrollment relationship
username and identifier okay
so yeah we are done with these two
methods we will need one last method
that is
we need public
list of courses
and we will call it
get all enrolled
course by username
string username and string identifier
okay so what this method is going to do
is if we give it a username
it will give us back the list of courses
the user is enrolled in and I just
realized we really do not need the
identifier here
now we do not have a repository method
for this so let's go to our course
Repository
and create a new method
this will return a list of courses and
we will call it find all
enrolled courses by
username
and we will receive I stream username
and then we can say query
match
we are trying to match a user
where the username
is username so this is another way of
doing a wire query or where clause
so we will have a user with the same
username that has been passed to this
method
then once we have that node we want to
get
enrolled in
courses course so we want to get all the
courses that has an outgoing
relationship with this user of type
enrolled in and I am saving all those
courses in the courses variable and I'll
just return
courses
and we will also import the list method
java.utl of course
and yeah that's it so let's go back here
and we will say
return
course repository dot find all enroll
course by username and we'll just pass
the username so that's it we have our
course enrollment service ready to go we
can use it to enroll our users in a new
course
we can get the enrollment status of a
user and we can also get all the
enrolled courses by
username
and I just realized it should be courses
and not just course
so there we go
okay now I think we are ready to create
a new controller
the controller will be named course
enrollment on
roller
like the other ones it's going to be a
rest controller for sure okay let's just
go back to our service class for a bit
course enrollment service and here we
have annotated it yeah and we will do a
request mapping
API slash V1 slash
enrollments
now these enrollments
endpoint these need to be protected
because if you go back to our service
for example course enrollment service
you can see all these methods needs to
know the username of the currently
authenticated user so for that we need
to protect this route
so we will leave the controller open and
get back to config and security config
let's let's close this
and come to the request matches part I
will put a comma
and I will say
API slash
V1
slash enrollments
slash double star which means
anything that comes after API slide V1
slash enrollment slash
anything should be authenticated or
protected let's close that
and inside our controller class
we will need a few services
so I will say private
final
course enrollment
service course enrollment service
and we will also need private
final
lesson service
lesson service because we will need to
know what lessons are part of a certain
course
now I will have my Constructor
and we can start working on the
endpoints
now the first one I want to do is uh I
want to let the user enroll in a course
so for that I will say
public
response entity of type
course in
enrollment dto
and we need to create this class create
class course enrollment tto and we want
to put it inside
the objects packets
and here we have our dto
we need string
private string username so the user
name of the user that has just enrolled
in the course private history name of
the user private
course
and the course that the user just
enrolled in
then we will have
a Constructor
and we will have the Getters and setters
yeah that's pretty much it
so you want to return a course
enrollment dto and we will call our
method
enroll in
now what we are going to take we are
going to take the request body
request body and we will create another
request called
course enrollment
request
let's hover over it and create type
parameter course enrollment request
uh you know what let's just copy the
name
go to Project
go to requests
create a new class
called course envelopment request
and inside this we need
private
string identifier this is the course
identifier of course
and we will
generate a Constructor
and the Getters and setters
okay let's go back to our code request
body course enrollment request so we
will have our course enrollment request
comma
another thing that we need is the
principle sorry I forgot to name this so
I will get the principal principle
because this is how you get the username
of the authenticated user now inside
this method we will say course
enrollment query result
let's call it enrollment quiz result yes
equals
we will say course enrollment service
dot enroll in
what is the username the principal dot
get name and what is the identifier
request dot get identifier
we have a new enrollment request query
right query result now we cannot just
return this query result for button
or verbatim rather we'll need a new dto
called
course enrollment TT
now I will over it
some more action
okay let's again just copy this go to
Project
go inside objects
oh it looks like we have a course
enrollment video grid I just forgot
about this
so what I will do is course enrollment
dto
we have that yeah I just forgot that we
created this
so response enrollment
equals new
the first thing that we need to pass is
the username so we will say enrollment
query result dot get
user dot get username because our query
result has a git user method
that in turn returns a get username
method and we can use that to get
the name of the user or the username of
the user next up we have the name of the
user so enrollment query result dot get
user once again
dot get name and you know what this line
is getting too big so I will just put it
in the next line
comma that's bring down here yeah much
better
enrollment query request Dot
get course
that's pretty much it all we need the
username name and the course
finally we can say return
uh
new response entity
the body will be the response enrollment
and the HTTP status should be okay but
it really depends upon you since we have
created a new relationship you could
have also returned created here but I'm
going to just return okay
now this is going to be a post mapping
let's try and enroll our user in a
course okay
let's check our request once again we
just need an identifier so that's what
we are going to do
I will go back to my
insomnia client
I would create a new request called
enroll
this is going to be http
localhost 8080
slash API slash C1 slash enrollments
and inside this has to be a post request
by the way and inside the body
we need
an identifier
so let's go inside get single course
this one
go back to enroll
and we put it here
let's click on send
I just remembered I didn't restart my
code
so let's go back to idea and do that
and I will send
nice we are getting a 401 unauthorized
response because we are not
authenticating any user so I will go to
basic auth
I'll add Farhan and password is password
let's send the request
so it looks like that we should leave
the course enrollment request as a empty
Constructor instead of taking the
identifier as one of its parameters
because
if we do that the request may not work
so I am keeping it empty
and now when I try to create a
enrollment from
insomnia it just works as you can see
Farhan has been enrolled in Blazer
shopping cart application course so to
verify we can quickly go to our rdb
dashboard and if we click on enrolled in
we should see that Farhan haseen
Chaudhary is now enrolled in the Blazer
shopping cart course
now other than verifying from the
database itself we also want a way to
get the list
of all the courses a user has been
enrolled in
so we have already created a service
method for that so let's just go back to
our controller and Implement that
so here inside our controller we will
create a new get mapping method
so public
response entity this is going to be a
list
of the course tto
and we will call it enrollments
we will take the principal because we
need the username
and inside this method we will say
list course
so courses equals course
enrollment service dot get all enrolled
course by username and we'll say
principle dot get name
now we have a list of courses that the
user has been enrolled in
on the next line we will say just like
before
a list
of course dto
and
response courses equals courses Dot
stream dot map
inside the map method
we will say course this is a Lambda
of course sorry
course t t o
response course equals
new course dto
and we need an identifier title and
teacher name so I will say course dot
get identifier
course dot get title
and course dot K8 teacher
and then I can just
return response course
and finally
after this curly brace and the last
parenthesis I will say collect
collectors talk to list so this is just
like we did before with the courses list
so I'm not going to again explain this
and I will say return new response
entity
response courses comma HTTP status dot
ok
all right we this is a get mapping of
course
there you go
let's restart our application
go back to insomnia make a copy of the
enroll
request and call it enrollments
turn it into a get request get rid of
the identifier make sure that we are
authenticating
and let's hit send
okay so looks like we have a list of the
courses that this user has been enrolled
in
what we need is we need the list of
lessons too so let's go back to our
controller
I am going to steal some code from
the course controller class
I hope you remember inside this one we
actually made use of the lesson service
so I'll copy this line
I'll go back to course enrollment
controller
and put it down here
course enrollment.setlesson
and then return the response course
we will rerun the application
we'll go back to insomnia resend our
request
and this time we are actually getting
the list of all the lessons as well now
that's pretty much it we have done a lot
with our applications except I want to
implement one last thing
in in our code
so I you may remember that we have
implemented the code necessary for a
service and repository method that
returns a Boolean based on whether an
user is enrolled in a course or not so
in our list of courses I would like to
add a new Boolean variable here that
says enrolled in and that will return
true if the user is enrolled in a course
and false in case he or she is not
enrolled in a course so let's go back to
our code
what we can do is
we will go back to our course dto
and inside we want to add a new Boolean
so private
Boolean
that's use a primitive type and is in
enrolled that's it
now
we will need a getter and Setter for
this one
foreign
yes we got that
now let's go back to course enrollment
controller
and we will say
response course dot set enrolled and we
are going to hard code it to True since
the user just enrolled in this course we
know for sure that this is going to be
true so we will not make another
database request and just write it as
true
but
inside our course controller
we will actually have to do a database
call
for that we will take the principle
and we will add a check here
we will say if
principal
is not null
then
response course dot set enrolled
inside we will say
we'll need another service private final
course enrollment service
enrollment service and we will say
that's a lot of politics do we must
course environment service yeah so
inside set enrolled we will say
course enrollment service
dot get enrollment status and principal
dot get name
and
course dot get identified
so we are checking whether the user has
enrolled in the course or not now why we
are checking for principle is null or
not I hope you remembered that in our
course index anyone can see the list of
our courses because it it's an open
directory so in case we do not get any
principal or authenticated user we will
just set it to false is set enrolled and
if we get a principal we will set it to
whatever the database returns so I will
rerun the application and show you how
it works
let's quickly switch to insomnia and get
all courses
so as you can see it says enrolled false
in all of these because I am not logged
in but if I log into my account Farhan
password
and hit send
you will see that it says true on the
Blazer shopping cart application and
falls in all of the other ones
now why we are here I thought I will
make one little adjustment to our code
that is in enroll
we are sending something called an
identifier now this is not clear I think
what would be better if we could call it
course identity fire
this is a lot better I think so I will
go back to my code
go inside the course enrollment request
right click on the identifier and go
inside refactor
rename
so instead of identifier I would like to
call it course identifier
I'll hit enter
yeah these are all the references
get course identifier question yes we
are going to
let's make sure that these are right
yeah let's hit okay
let's rerun our application and see
everything works fine or not
okay it looks fine
so that's pretty much it we have
successfully implemented the ability to
enroll in a new course the user can get
the list of enrollments the user can
register the user can sign in and
see the lessons in the course
now on the next part of this course
Kevin lawn will walk you through the
entire process of creating and react app
based on this API he will show how you
can use the identifiers to get the
corresponding YouTube videos and how you
can basically create a course management
system front end for yourself powered by
my API
now one last challenge that I would like
to leave for the user
is inside the services and course
enrollment service
before we enroll our user in a course we
need to
make sure that the user has
not been enrolled in the course already
so this is something that we have to
make sure right now if you try to enroll
the same user twice in a course you will
create two relationships to the same
course so it will get you will get
double results
so what you should do is you should
check whether the user has already been
enrolled in the course using the can
enrollment status maybe I don't know I'm
giving a hint
and then you should enroll the user in
the course or return something else now
this is another challenge that I am
leaving up to you so if you go inside to
do you will get three to-do's
and one is in the config and two is in
the services so make sure that you are
completing your challenges it will give
you a lot more confidence to be honest
and you will learn a lot from your
researches make sure that you leave the
link to your repository in the comment
section below I will come there I will
check the course submissions and
I think it would be a nice conversation
between us so I hope that throughout
this entire course or this part of the
course you have learned something about
the neo4j database
which truly is an amazing technology you
have learned how to create an API
powered by neo4j on Spring boot and a
few other things here and there on how
to structure your application how to use
an IDE and things like that
so if you ever need any help just give
me a shout out in the comment section I
would love to help
and best of luck for the rest of the
course Gavin long is an amazing
instructor and I can say for sure that
you will have a great time
so until the next time
take care and be careful bye
before we get started with coding this
react application I need to let you know
that I've had to make a few assumptions
regarding the knowledge and experience
of the viewers of this part of the
course
so ideally the viewer of this part of
the course should have at least a basic
knowledge of react JavaScript HTML and
CSS
so let's start with the very Basics we
of course need a code editor for writing
our react code
I will be using visual studio code for
Windows for this purpose
you can download visual studio code for
Windows from this URL
in order to run our code locally we need
to install node.js
you can install node.js from this URL
node.js is an open source cross-platform
JavaScript runtime environment
we need a local working directory to
house our applications code
so please create a working folder in a
location of your choosing on your
computer
and let's give our working folder a
sensible name my working folder for this
project is curriculum mngt management
client so curriculum mngt client then
let's open the working directory for our
project within Visual Studio code note
we can check what version of node we
have installed while we're in Visual
Studio code we can do this by first
launching the terminal window
launch the terminal window by pressing
Ctrl and the tilde character
then add the command prompt type node
Dash V and press enter
great and we can see what version of
node we have installed on our computers
an easy way to set up a react project
is to use the create Dash react Dash app
command
we can use this command to generate the
infrastructure for our react application
when I say infrastructure I mean the
node modules that are necessary for
harnessing foundational react
functionality is generated through the
use of the create react app command
there are other ways perhaps better ways
of creating the foundations for a react
project like for example using a
technology named Veet for this purpose
if you are interested please read more
about Veet at this location
using the create react app command
provides a simple way to create a react
project so I'm going to use the create
react app command for this purpose
add the command prompt type npx create
react app followed by a sensible name
for your react application I'm going to
name my react application curriculum
dash mngt mngt of course stands for
management then let's press the enter
key this process may take a while so
this will give you an opportunity to
contemplate life the universe okay you
don't have to do that but you may want
to get yourself a cup of tea or
something like that while you wait
okay great
and you can see that the foundation for
our react project has been generated
the node modules directory has been
created which contains all the react
dependencies and packages needed to
build and run a react project
as you can see a new root directory for
our project has been generated that is
of the name that we gave our application
when we ran the create react app command
so for better Clarity let's open another
instance of Visual Studio code where the
newly created project directory is the
root directory within Visual Studio code
to do this let's make sure the terminal
window is launched remember you can do
this by pressing the control key and the
tilde key
then at the command prompt
make sure the current Project's working
directory is the current directory at
the command prompt then type CD space
and then the root directory
of the react project then press the
enter key
now at the command prompt
type code followed by a space and then
the period character then press the
enter key
this will result in a new instance of
Visual Studio code being presented and
now the react project folder is the root
directory
now let's close the previously launched
instance of Visual Studio code
the create react app command has
generated the infrastructure for our
react project but has also generated a
few files that we don't need so let's
delete the following files that we don't
need report web vitals.js
setuptests.js and app.test.js
foreign
we must also delete the eslint config
setting from the package.json file here
let's save our changes
then lastly let's open the index.js file
and delete the code regarding report web
vitals
great
so we are now ready to develop our react
application so at the moment we have
very basic functionality that has been
generated for us by default through the
use of the create react app command
so let's ensure that we start off on a
good footing as it were
this lets us know
that all is working as it should be
before we start developing our
application
so to launch the react app in our
default browsers we can type npm space
start at the command prompt and press
the enter key
great and we can see the react logo
spinning which means we are good to go
so let's start creating the code for our
application within the SRC directory
where the source code will reside let's
create a subdirectory named components
as you have probably guessed we are
going to create our react components
within the components directory
let's also create a directory within the
SRC directory named images
please download this image from this
location on GitHub and ensure that this
image file resides within the images
directory we are going to use this image
as our hero image on our home page so
this image will be referenced from
within the home component the first
react component we are going to create
is the home component this component
denotes the page that will first be
displayed when our application is first
launched
so let's create a directory within the
components folder named home the first
letter of this folder name should be in
lower case
within the home folder let's create a
file named home.js
the first letter of this file should be
an uppercase
so we can use a shortcut to generate
boilerplate code for our home component
to do this type rafce like this within
the code editor and press the enter key
note that in order to utilize the rafce
shortcut you must first install the
appropriate react Snippets extension if
this extension is currently not
installed this installation can easily
be done through the extensions tab
within Visual Studio code
at the top of the home.js file let's
import the hero image from within the
images directory like this
let's include an image tag within the
jsx code return from the home component
then let's open the app.js file let's
import the home component into the app
component with this line of code
let's delete the code that we don't need
but ensure that we leave the div root
element that contains the class name
attribute that references the app.css
class
then let's appropriately reference the
home element by including the home tag
within the div parent tag like this
let's type npm start to fire up our
application
great but the image looks huge and is
not displayed appropriately for our hero
image so we are going to use bootstrap
to style this hero image so to install
bootstrap type this command at your
command prompt and press enter
to have access throughout our
application to relevant bootstrap
classes we must include this import
statement within the index.js file
now within the roots div tag of the home
component let's include the class name
attribute and set it to the bootstrap
class named container like this
let's run our code
What's Happening Here is the image is
still too large for its container
element
so to remedy this let's create a scoped
CSS style sheet for the home component
so let's create a file within the home
directory named home.css within the
home.css file let's create a reference
to the relevant image within the
container div tag like this and let's
set the image width to 100 percent
within the home component let's create a
reference to the home.css file with this
line of code
let's type npm start at the terminal
prompt to launch our application
and that is much better great
so that is a great start but we are also
going to need some other third-party
packages dependencies in order to
integrate certain functionality into our
application for example we want to
install the react router Dom package
that will be instrumental in the Global
Management of our menu and Link
functionality our navigation
functionality
we are going to use the react player
component for displaying videos that
denote lessons for our courses to our
users
we'll use axios to manage our client
interactions with a server-side web API
component so here we have used
bootstraps container class to house our
hero image so that it is appropriately
displayed within our home component as a
hero image
we can also leverage bootstrap by using
components that reside within the react
bootstrap package we'll look at using
such components a bit later in this
video
for now let's install react bootstrap to
install react bootstrap type npm space i
space react Dash bootstrap and press the
enter key
great
let's install the axios library
we are going to use axios for making our
HTTP client requests to the relevant
server-side endpoints
so as to return the relevance data from
the neo4j database that hosts the
relevant curriculum data that we want to
display to our users we'll also use
axios
to implement the enroll functionality
I.E this is functionality whereby a user
can enroll in a particular course
we could use the windows.fetch function
which is available by default within our
browsers for this purpose instead of
axios but axios provides us with key
advantages please navigate to this URL
if you'd like to learn more about these
key advantages
this link is available Below in the
description of this video
to install axios type npm space install
space axios and then press the enter key
the next packages I would like to
install allow us to leverage font
awesome from within our react
applications so at the command prompt
please type npm space i space at Fort
awesome
forward slash react Dash font awesome
and then press the enter key
let's install one more font awesome
related package
to do this type npm space i space at
Fort awesome forward slash free dash
solid-svg dash icons and then press the
enter key
great
we'll look at the details of using the
relevant font Dash awesome functionality
a little bit later in this video
the next component I want to install is
react player
this will allow us to play YouTube
videos from within our react application
the individual lessons within the
courses in which our user is enrolled
will be presented to the user as videos
these videos reside on the YouTube
platform
so to install react player type npm
space i space react dash player at the
command prompt and then press the enter
key
then let's install react router Dom
which allows us to leverage Rich
navigation and routing functionality
from within our react application to
install react router Dom
add your command prompt please type npm
space i space react Dash router Dom and
then press the enter key
if we open the package.json file you can
see the relevance dependencies that we
have just installed great
so let's create the navigation bar that
will appear at the top of our
applications UI so this can be referred
to as the header for our application
the navigation bar will contain a
register and login button
and relevant navigation menu options
so let's create a folder within the
components directory named header
please ensure that the H in header used
to name our folder is in lower case
let's create a file for the header
component and let's name it header.js
where the H is an uppercase
so we are going to use Font awesome in
this component to display a graduation
cap as the logo for our application
which will appear in the top left hand
corner of the user's screen
so let's write code to import the
relevant font awesome components
then we are going to use react bootstrap
for our buttons so let's import the
button component from the react
bootstrap package
with this line of code
we are going to use the container
component for layout purposes
let's import the nav component from
react bootstrap
which will be used for layout and
styling purposes let's also import the
navbar component for the purpose of
styling our navigation display lastly
let's import the use navigate Hook and
the nav link component from the react
rooted on package so that we can
Leverage The relevant react router Dom
functionality for navigation purposes
let's change the div tag to be a navbar
tag within the navbar element let's
include a container element let's
include the fluid keyword within the
container element
this will ensure that the navigation bar
spans the entire width of the web page
rather than placed centrally within the
web page let's reference the
navbar.brand react bootstrap element and
set its class name property to the menu
Dash link bootstrap class like this
then let's include the graduation cap
font awesome icon like this as a child
element of the navbar.brand element this
icon serves as our applications logo
let's include the navbar.toggle element
here
which will allow the navigation to be
shown and hidden through a toggle
mechanism made available to the user on
smaller screen sizes so as you can see
bootstrap is great for responsive
layouts
so let's include the nav element and
let's style the nav element
appropriately
let's include the button component
to represent our login button
the variant property is set to info as a
style choice
let's set the class name property to a
bootstrap class named me-2 this is so
that our buttons are spaced
appropriately
let's include the register button which
will appear to the right of the login
button on our navigation bar and let's
dial the register button in the same way
that we have styled the login button
right let's open the apps.js file and
firstly make sure that we are importing
the header component into the app
component
then let's include the header element
reference just above the home tag within
the jsx code that will be returned from
the app component
let's use npm start to launch the
application so that we can view what our
navigation bar currently looks like
great
okay because our navigation bar is
currently White
our brand icon is also White
so we can't currently see our graduation
cap brand
so let's change the color to Red for now
great okay
so I want to make the background for our
application as black
and address styling features that I'd
like to apply to all of our components
one way we can do this is to include the
relevant styling code within the app.css
file which is referenced by the app
component the app component is the
parent component for all our bespoke
child components so the Styles included
within the app.css file will propagate
to all the app components child
components so let's firstly import the
quicksand font from Google through this
line of code we want the quicksand font
to be applied for our entire web
application
let's use the star like this to indicate
the following CSS properties applied to
the roots tag for our single page
application
so let's first set the Border Dash
sizing property to borderbox
if you set the Box Dash sizing property
to border box on elements like this the
padding and Border values are included
in the width and height properties for
the relevant elements
let's set the font Dash family property
to quicksand
right let's create the styling for the
app element
let's set the app Root elements
background color to Black
let's set the color for our text to
White
let's set the top margin for the app
element to 10 pixels
let's launch the app
great
okay so let's create the component that
will house the registration
functionality this component will
contain a form that the user can fill
out to register the user's relevant
details with the system
including the user's name username and
password the fields on the form will be
name username password and confirm
password
we'll incorporate regular Expressions
into this dialog for the purpose of
validating each of these fields each of
these fields will be validated in real
time IE as the user enters the relevant
information into the relevant text box
controls so let's start by creating a
folder named register within the
components folder
let's add a file named register.js
within the register folder
and let's also create a file named
register.css
let's go to the register component
let's import the use statehook and the
use ref hook into our component so the
use statehook is used to track the state
of relevant variables
when the state for a particular variable
changes react detects this and
re-renders the relevant component in the
user's browser
this use ref hook will be used to
reference a text box form control
let's import relevant react bootstrap
components
let's import relevant font awesome
let's use rafce to generate the
boilerplate code for our register
component let's declare a constant named
name ref which will be used to reference
the name text box control
let's use the use statehook to monitor a
variable named name the set name
function will be used to change the
state of the name variable the name
variable will be bound as it were to the
relevant text box control where the user
will enter the user's name
let's include a Boolean variable for the
purpose of monitoring the valid or
invalid state of the text value entered
into the name control by the user let's
create two variables that are used for
the same functionality as the previous
two variables
that we have created
but are applied to the username text box
control so when the username is deemed
as valid the valid username variable is
set to True conversely when the username
variables value is deemed as invalid the
valid username value is set to false
let's do the same for the password or
PWD field I.E create two appropriate
variables where their state is tracked
let's do the same regarding the confirm
password field which is used to validate
if the confirm password field matches
the password field
so I've already prepared the regular
expressions for the relevant Fields off
screen
please feel free to copy the relevant
regular expressions from this location
on GitHub
so let's set a constant to the regular
expression that will be used for
validating the name field please
remember if you get stuck or you wish to
copy and paste the code rather than
following along with creating the code
line by line with me you are able to
copy the relevant code from a GitHub
repository available at this location
so this regular expression will ensure
that the name field has at least two
characters and no numbers are included
so let's include the regular expression
for the username field
the validation Criterion for this
regular expression means that the
username must be between 8 to 20
characters long
no underscore or period characters are
included at the beginning
no double underscore or underscore
period characters or period underscore
characters or dot dot characters are
included within the field and no
underscore or dot characters appear at
the end of the word
so this regular expression is used for
the password field this regular
expression means that in order for the
password field to be deemed as valid a
minimum of 8 characters must be included
the password must include at least one
letter one number and one special
character
so let's apply the use effect hook so
that a function that we'll write
that is passed as an argument to the use
effect Hook is fired when the register
component first loads so the use effect
hook accepts two arguments the first
argument is the function to be fired and
the second argument determines when the
function is fired
so we want the function passed in as the
first argument to be fired when the
register component is first loaded so we
can achieve this by passing in empty
square brackets as an argument to the
second parameter of the uzi Fair tug
so we want the name control to receive
focus when the register component first
loads we can achieve this with this line
of code
we'll write the code to create the
relevant form controls including the
name control in just a bit
and this will of course be implemented
within the jsx section of this component
let's use the use effect hook to monitor
the state of the name variable which
will be changed with every key press
that the user makes within the name text
box which as I've said will be created
soon
so to do this
we pass a function as the first argument
to the use effect hook that we want
fired when the state of the name
variable changes then in order to tell
react as it were that we only want the
relevant function to fire when the name
variable States changes we can pass the
name variable within square brackets as
the second argument to the use effect
hook
note that the test method is executed on
the relevant regular expression to
ascertain whether or not the name
entered by the user is valid or not
the result returned from this line of
code will either be true or false
we can then set the state of the valid
name Boolean variable to the result
returned from the test function
we'll create UI functionality to show
that the name field is valid or invalid
in just a bit so we are providing the
user with real-time validation feedback
as the user types the user's name into
the name field
then let's apply another use effect hook
to perform similar functionality for the
username
let's apply another use effect hook
to check that the password is valid or
invalid based on the relevant regular
expression
then we must also check whether the
password field matches the confirm
password field
note that within the array passed in as
an arguments to the second parameter of
the use effect hook
is the variable representing the
password field
and the variable representing the
confirm password field
so this means that each time the
password or confirm password Fields
change
the relevant validation functionality is
executed we'll wire up the relevant
variables to their counterpart text box
form controls in just a bit you'll see
that the on change event of the relevant
form controls is used for this purpose
right so let's create the jsx code
within the relevant section of the
register component let's create a
container component
let's create an appropriate heading
let's create a main element and a div
element within the main element
please include the relevant class name
attributes and values within the
relevant elements
let's include the react bootstrap form
element
so each text box control will reside
within a form dot group element which
will also include a label control
so let's create the relevant code for
the name text box control
the form.label element contains a span
element here
we have a ternary operator that shows or
hides either a font awesome times icon
or a tick icon based on whether the
valid name variable is true or false so
this span element will be shown to the
user based on whether the span elements
class name property references the CSS
class named valid or the CSS class named
hide we'll create these CSS classes in
just a bit
so if the valid name value is true the
fa check icon is displayed next to the
name text box control conversely if the
valid name variable is set to false this
span element is displayed to the user
which means the fa times or a cross icon
is displayed to the user indicating that
what the user has entered into the name
field is currently invalid then let's
create the text box control for the name
field like this
note that we are setting the ref
property to the name ref const this
allows us to reference the text box
within the relevant use effect hook
where we have created code so that the
name text box is given focus when the
register component first loads
then the on change event is wired up to
an arrow function that sets the tracked
name variable every time the user
changes the text entered within the name
text box
let's create the form control code for
the username field which contains
similar functionality
let's create the form control code for
the password field
and the confirm password field
let's create the code for a submit
button so we want to disable this submit
button while any of the relevant form
fields are not valid so let's set the
relevant disabled property to this
Boolean expression
so before we test the validation code
for our register form let's set up the
roots for our application
so that we can navigate to the register
component through the navigation bar
that has been created within our header
component so let's open the app.js file
let's import The Roots component and the
root component from within the react
router Dom package let's include the
roots element below the header element
we want the header elements to appear
regardless of where the user navigates
to within our application so we need the
header appropriately displayed outside
the roots element
within the roots element let's include
the relevant roots
where we can tell react rooted arm as it
were about the paths of our components
we haven't yet created the layout
component so let's do that now the
layout component provides instructions
to react as it were regarding the
overall layout of the relevant
components that are mapped to relevant
roots
let's import the layout component
we also need to create a route for the
app component and we must do this within
the index.js file
we need to wrap this route within the
browser router component as well as the
roots component like this
let's go back to the header component
and create code so that when the
register button is clicked that the
register component is appropriately
loaded
let's create a const named navigate that
is assigned a function returned from the
use navigate hook
let's create a reusable function named
handlenav
let's use the navigate function to
navigate the user to a path passed in to
the handlenev function
let's pass in the relevant path to the
register components to the handle Now
function so when the register button is
clicked the register component is loaded
Let's test the code
okay so to fix this issue we need to
correct a typo here
where we have incorrectly named the
regular expression const pertaining to
the username field
great but in order for our validation to
work as expected we need to create the
relevant CSS classes
let's make sure that we import the
register.css file into the register
component let's open the register.css
file and create the code for the
relevant CSS classes
let's create the CSS code for the
register Dash container class which will
make sure the layout for the register
dialog is appropriate
we are using the flexgrid functionality
to appropriately handle the layout let's
include the register Dash layout class
to handle the layout for the register
form
let's include the valid class so that
the elements referencing this class are
appropriately displayed
let's include the hide class so the
elements referencing this class are
appropriately hidden
let's include a class named invalid Dash
icon to display the times or cross font
awesome icon in red let's include a
class named valid icon to display the
checked icon or tick font awesome icon
in Green Let's include a class named
register Dash message
which will style a displayed message to
the user that is centrally aligned and
in white text the appropriate text will
display once a user has successfully
registered
Let's test the UI validation
functionality for the name field
functionality for the username field
okay
so we have an issue the name field is
also being affected
this should not be happening let's look
at the code
okay so within this use effect hook lies
the problem we are currently using the
set valid name function here whereas we
should of course be using the set valid
username function here
so let's fix this
great
Let's test the password field and the
confirm password field validation
functionality
oops and of course the password control
should be of type password and not text
we must of course also make the same fix
for the confirm password control
excellent
so let's go back to the register.css
file and make sure our register form is
responsive on smaller screen sizes
so let's use an appropriate media query
for this purpose
excellent
so now we want to interface with the
neo4j database hosted in the cloud
so we are going to download the code for
the HTTP based web API component written
in Java to our local machine so we are
going to host the web API component on
our local machines just to make the
development of our application a bit
easier
this web API component is hosted using
spring boot in order to be able to run
this code locally on a Windows computer
you must ensure that you have the Java
jdk installed on your local machine
if you don't yet have the Java jdk
installed please navigate to this URL
then follow the instructions for
installing the Java jdk Java jdk version
20 or version 17 should be fine
the next step is to clone the GitHub
repository at this URL onto your local
machine this GitHub repository contains
the Java code for the relevant web API
so we are hosting the server-side code
on our local machines we are connecting
to a neo4j database hosted in the cloud
from our local machines
please remember the local directory that
contains the cloned GitHub repository
code
we need to run a command at the command
line later on to run the relevant web
API component as stated before this will
be run locally
please ensure that you have configured
the web API component correctly to point
to the neo4j database that you have
created if you are unsure of how to do
this please follow the relevant
instructions provided in the previous
part of this course
the values I'm showing you here will of
course not apply to your particular
environment
for now let's create the client-side
react code to connect to the locally
hosted web API component
so let's create a folder within the SRC
folder named API
within the API folder let's create a
file named axiosconfig.js
let's first write code for importing
axios
let's create the code to set up the
axios client component
so let's add the base URL property
and set it to localhost port 8080 which
is where we will be able to connect to
the relevant web API endpoints this web
API component of course handles calls to
the relevant neo4j database that is
hosted in the cloud let's create
appropriate code for the headers
property
now let's go to the register component
and import the axios client component
let's create a JavaScript function named
post data
we must include the E dot prevent
default line of code for when submitting
a form from within a react component
because we'll be using the on submit
event for the submission of the register
form
then let's create an object that
encapsulates the data entered by the
user I'm going to hard code the roles
value here which is okay for demo
purposes but you'd want to handle this
field more appropriately for a
production environment for example you
could have a list of roles presented to
the user in a list box control and the
user can select the relevant role from
the list box control right so we can
write code for post requests using the
axios client component like this
so we are simply posting the object we
have just created
to an appropriate endpoint created for
handling the register post request
we can include basic error handling code
through the use of try catch code and we
can output an appropriate message to the
user regarding whether the user has been
registered successfully or not
let's include code at the bottom of the
form to display this registration status
information
let's first set the submit success
message appropriately based on the
response returned from the server-side
code
and at the bottom of the register form
let's write the code to display the
relevant message saved within the submit
success variable
so let's set the Min height property of
the app parent component so that it
extends to the bottom of the web page
and we can do this by setting the Min
height property here so that its minimum
height is 100 VH
so the result of this is that the
background color will be black
regardless of which component is loaded
because the relevant components are all
child components of the app parent
component
and of course we must wire up the on
submit event
to an appropriate event handler so we
are wiring up the on submit event to the
post data method within the form element
like this okay
so to run the web API component on your
computer
you can run this command at your command
prompt
so launch the command prompt as
administrator change the current
directory to the root directory of where
you cloned the relevant Java code
locally
just a reminder the relevant Java code
can be found at this location on GitHub
so once you have done that type this
command at your command prompt
and press enter after you press the
enter key you should see similar
information to the information displayed
on my screen logged to your screen
let's run the react code and see if we
can register a user
oops we have a bug here
we are referencing a control named PWD
with the object that we are attempting
to post
ewd field doesn't exist because we named
the relevant field password so let's fix
this
we have successfully registered a user
so we are now successfully communicating
from the react client code with the Java
server-side code which for development
purposes we are currently hosting on our
local machines
so we have successfully registered a
user the next logical step is to create
the login functionality
let's create a folder named login and
let's ensure that the first character is
lowercase within the login folder let's
create a file named login.js and let's
ensure that the first character of the
file name is an uppercase
let's create the file within the login
folder named login.css
right let's write the code for the login
component let's reference the login.css
file let's import the relevant
dependencies
let's import the use State use effect
and use ref hooks from react
let's import the container component
from the react bootstrap package
let's import the button components from
the reactor bootstrap package
let's import the form component from the
react bootstrap package
let's appropriately import the axios
client component
let's import the use navigate hook the
link component and the use location Hook
from react router Dom
let's create the boilerplate code for
our component by appropriately typing
rafce and pressing the enter key
great
let's create a const named navigate
and assign it to Value returned from the
use navigate hook
we will be able to use the function
assigned to the navigate const in code
for navigation purposes
let's assign a value returned from the
use ref hook to the user ref const
this will allow us to reference a
specific form control within a function
we'll look at this functionality in just
a bit in order to track the state of the
username let's use the you state hook
for this purpose
so user is a variable we want tracked by
react and we must use the set user
function to change the state of the user
variable
let's use the use statehook to track the
state of the entered password
let's use the use effect hook so that a
function executes when the login
component first loads
the code for this function simply sets
the username field to have a focus and
this happens when the login component is
first loaded
let's create the UI code for our login
component within the jsx section of our
component
so let's first reference the react
bootstrap container component so that
our login form is housed as it were
within an element that references the
container bootstrap Style
let's create a heading for our login
form
for styling purposes let's create a main
element and within that a div element
Within These elements our references to
appropriate CSS classes we'll create the
code for these CSS classes in just a bit
so like with the registration dialog we
create a form element and within the
form element the relevant form controls
within form.group elements these
components are imported from the react
bootstrap package and we are using them
for layout and styling purposes so each
of the form groups contain a label and a
text box
so we have the username field and the
password field within the login form
note how we are using the on change
event to change the state of relevant
variables as the user changes the text
within the relevant text box controls
let's reference the button component and
this button will serve as the login
forms submit button
please remember if you get lost at any
point while following along the full
code is available at this location on
GitHub
the link to this GitHub repository is
available in the description of this
video
let's create an arrow function to handle
the submit functionality
so let's use this code to reference the
values that the user has entered into
the username field and the password
field
let's Implement basic exception handling
through the use of try catch
functionality
basic authentication has been
implemented in the web API component
please navigate to this URL if you'd
like to learn more about basic
Authentication
so in terms of basic authentication we
must encode the username and password
values in a particular format before we
submit a particular HTTP request to the
server-side code in order to implement
basic authentication on the client we
are going to pass the username and
password in a particular format through
the header of a HTTP get request for
this particular login component the
relevant format for the username and
password is username colon password
this is essential for basic
authentication we must also encode the
username colon password value in base64
encoding
we can use javascript's btoa function
for this purpose
so let's create a const named b64 in
code and assign it the value of username
colon password
that is base64 encoded using the btoa
JavaScript function the next step is to
create an object representing the Header
information that will be passed to the
relevant web API endpoint
so let's create a const named config and
set it to an object to represent
appropriate HTTP Header information this
object contains a property named headers
which is set to an object
with a property named authorization the
authorization property is set to the
text value basic followed by a space
followed by the base 64 encoded username
colon password text value
note we are wrapping the value assigned
to the authorization property in
backtick characters
so that we can interpolate the relevant
text value this means we can include a
variable within the baptic characters by
wrapping the variable within curly
brackets and preceding the curly
brackets with the dollar symbol
let's create a request to the relevant
endpoint using axios note we are passing
in the username and password through a
HTTP get request made to the relevant
endpoint through the config object
the config object contains the
authentication details for the user
which is appropriately added to the
header of the relevant HTTP get request
so before we test the login
functionality let's make sure that an
appropriate route is set up for the
login component
so let's open the app.js file and
include the code for the relevant root
let's import the login component into
the app component
and include code that represents the
route for the login component
let's open the header.js file and
include navigation functionality in this
component so that the user can navigate
to the login component by clicking the
login button displayed on the navigation
bar
Let's test the code
we have a few issues here so let's fix
these issues
please see the relevant GitHub code at
this location if you get stuck on any
issues
here this should be used State and not
use ref
there are also a few other issues that
need to be fixed so let's fix these
issues
let's run the code
so we have our login form presented to
the user but it doesn't look great we'll
fix this in just a bit so off screen I
registered a user named Henry Jamison
please feel free to register your own
users while testing
I'm going to test the login
functionality using Henry Jamison's
credentials
I'm going to use a simple JavaScript
alert to ensure that the HTTP status
sent back from the relevant endpoint is
200 meaning that the HTTP request has
been successfully processed on the
server
excellent we have received a response
with a status code of 200 so we've
received a HTTP response with a status
code of 200 meaning success
so next let's style the login screen
appropriately
let's open the login.css file let's
style the CSS class named login Dash
container
we are using the flex grid for styling
and layout purposes the flex grid is
great for creating responsive UI code
for various screen sizes let's create
the login Dash layout CSS class
we are also using the flexgrid
functionality here note that we are
setting the flex Direction property to
column which means the relevant elements
will stack one on top of the other in a
column layout by default if the flex
Direction property is not set this
setting defaults to row this means the
relevant elements are presented one next
to the other in a row layout
let's give each of these form.group
elements suitable margin bottom settings
using bootstrap
so that we are creating appropriate
spacing between the form groups
so that our layout here is a bit neater
great
let's include an error message at the
bottom of our form for if something goes
wrong during the authentication process
so let's set the state of an appropriate
error message based on the response
provided by the server
so if a status code of 200 is returned
from the server the state of the ER
message variable
can be set to an empty string or if the
status code does not indicate success or
an error is thrown we can set the ER
message variable appropriately to
indicate that the login has failed on
the server if an exception is thrown we
can include the error message that has
been caught within the try catch block
then let's output the value stored in
the ER message variable to the screen at
the bottom of the login form
let's style the error message display
appropriately
so to test this I'm going to force a 404
exception meaning that the relevant
endpoint is not found
by changing the endpoint path to
something that isn't correct
great
lastly let's ensure that our login form
looks good on smaller screens so to do
this within the login.css file let's
include appropriate media query
functionality
let's include code here to automatically
navigate the user to the home page once
the user has successfully logged in
excellent great so once the user has
been authenticated we want our other
components to know as it were that the
user is logged into the system so the
best way to do this is through the use
of context
react context is a way to manage State
globally so very basically we use react
context so that other components will be
able to retrieve a value
from a global store and assess whether a
user is logged into the system or not
logged into the system
for more information about react context
please navigate to this URL
so in order to create context let's
create a folder named context within the
SRC folder
within the context folder let's create a
file named auth provider.js
let's import the create context function
and the use statehook from react
let's set a const named auth context to
a value returned from the create context
method like this
note that we are passing an empty object
to the create context function let's
write code to export a component named
auth provider note that this code simply
means that the auth variable and set
auth function will be passed down to all
components that are wrapped by the auth
provider component so this makes these
accessible to the relevant child
components that are wrapped by the auth
provider parent component we'll look at
this in just a bit so what this means is
that all relevant components will be
able to access the auth variable with an
all relevant child components if the
auth variable is not null this means
that the relevant user has been
authenticated I.E logged onto the system
of course the state of the auth variable
is managed through the use of the use
statehook implemented within the auth
provider component
let's create a folder named hooks within
the SRC folder within the hooks folder
let's create a hook named use auth this
code basically allows relevant
components to access the auth context
which means access is provided to the
auth variable and the set off function
the set or function of course is used
for changing the state of the auth
variable so to log in you change the
state of the auth variable and to log
out you appropriately change the state
of the auth variable by setting it to
null the auth variable State indicates
whether the user is logged into the
system and the set auth function can be
used to change the state of the auth
variable
so the set or function can essentially
be used to log the user into the system
or out of the system let's create a hook
named use axios private
so the code for the hook is created so
that the client code can retrieve an
appropriate axios client object that
automatically includes an appropriate
HTTP header containing the logged on
user's credentials these credentials are
appropriately formatted for basic
Authentication so The Returned axios
client object from this hook must be
used for accessing protected resources
on the server I.E retrieved through the
relevant API endpoints these protected
resources require basic authentication
to be performed before returning
relevant data to the client
now the code here creates what's known
as an Interceptor so if they use axios
private Hook is used from within client
code to reference the axios client the
login credentials are automatically
injected into the header of the relevant
HTTP request so this means that the
client code doesn't need to inject this
authentication Header information every
time a HTTP request is made to an end
point this Interceptor code does this
automatically just a reminder if you get
stuck creating this code please
reference the relevant code at this
GitHub repository location
so the next step is to open the index.js
file and wrap all the relevant
components within the auth provider
parent component as discussed this
allows the child components or makes
Provisions for the child component to
easily access the auth variable so that
the relevant component can access
whether the user is logged into the
system or not logged into the system
so let's look at how this works let's
open the home.js file let's import the
use auth hook
let's use the use auth hook
to return the auth variable and the set
or function from the relevant context
Global store
now within the UI jsx code section of
the home component we can check the auth
variable to see if the user is logged
into the system like this
so if the user is logged into the system
the code displays a message on the
screen you are logged in if the user is
not logged into the system the code
displays the hero image to the screen so
let's open the login.js file and use the
use auth hook to return the set or
function from the context
let's use the set auth function to
assign an appropriate object to the auth
variable this object contains the
username and password
so once the user is successfully
authenticated
an object containing the user's username
and password
is passed into the set or function which
effectively changes the state of the
auth variable
which indicates of course that the user
is logged into the system
so you can see that now this Global
context can be used to retrieve the
username and password from this object
I.E the object that we have just passed
in to the set auth function to change
the state of the auth variable
the username and password can now be
injected into the header of HTTP
requests through the Interceptor
functionality that we have implemented
in the use axios private hook
let's run the code
let's register a new user named Brandon
Lowe
okay the password Here is password 1
exclamation mark
let's then log into the system
excellent
so let's create our logout functionality
within the header component
let's retrieve the auth variable and the
set auth function from the use auth hook
so if the auth.user property is not null
this means that the user is logged into
the system
so we want a log out button to be
displayed in the navigation bar rather
than the login and registration buttons
when a user is logged into the system we
only want the login and registration
buttons presented to the user when the
user is not logged into the system let's
create a function for when the logout
button is clicked
so let's create this logout function
within this function we can simply set
the auth variable to null by using the
set auth function for this purpose this
effectively means that the user is now
logged out of the system
then let's also Implement code to
navigate the user to the home component
right let's log into the system
great
let's log out of the system
excellent
so let's create the code within the home
component so that when the user is
authenticated a list of courses is
displayed to the user rather than the
hero image
let's create code using the use
statehook
so that react monitors the state of a
variable named course data we can change
the state of the course data variable
using the set course data function
returned from the use statehook
let's use the use axios private hook to
return a reference to the axios client
that we are going to use to request a
list of courses from the server
note we are getting a reference to the
axios client using the use axios private
hook because the use axios private hook
contains functionality that will
automatically inject the logged on
user's credentials into the header of
the relevant HTTP request so each
request to the server requires the
user's credentials so that basic
authentication can be appropriately
performed
this is because the course data is a
protected resource so the user must be
authenticated before this course
information is passed from server to
client remember implemented within the
use axios privatehook is Interceptor
functionality so the HTTP request is
intercepted and the relevant
authentication information is injected
into the header of the HTTP request but
for the relevant HTTP request is made to
the server
so let's create a JavaScript Arrow
function named fetch courses so here a
get request is made
and once the results are returned we are
using the set course data function to
appropriately change the state of the
course data variable this results in the
home component re-rendering which means
a list of courses will be displayed on
the UI once the data becomes available
and the set course data function is
appropriately called to change the state
of the course data variable we'll
implement the code for displaying the
course data on the UI in just a bit
let's use the use a fat hook to call the
fetch data function when the home
component first loads but we only want
the fetch data function to be called if
the user is logged into the system
let's display the course data value in
an alert to test our HTTP get request
let's run the code
oops we currently are not importing the
use statehook let's fix this
we now have a 404 error this is
occurring because we need to include a
forward slash at the end of the endpoint
path here
let's try again
and we are getting the expected Json
results with a now alert this means our
HTTP request is working as expected
right so let's write the code for
displaying the course data on the UI
so in the return section of the home
component let's implement the code for
displaying the course data
I'm going to create this code fairly
quickly with minimal explanation
so we are using the map function here to
iterate through the courses list
returned from the server this courses
list is stored within the course data
variable
so I'm deliberately not providing a lot
of explanation here please note that
this part of the course is not a
detailed guide on bootstrap or even
react for that matter this part of the
course has been created for the purpose
of placing the advantages provided
through the use of the neo4j graph
database management system in the
context of a web-based application
please feel free to copy the relevant
code from GitHub the first map function
let's refer to this as the parent map
function traverses the list of courses
note that we are outputting the title
for each course within the parent map
function this title property
will be returned from the relevant
endpoint
within the parent map function another
map function is implemented that
traverses a list of lessons the lessons
make up the relevant course
so we are outputting the title of the
course as a heading a list of lessons is
outputted for each of the relevant
courses underneath the relevant heading
so essentially the data is grouped by
course
the title for each course and the
course's lessons are outputted to the UI
bootstrap is being used for layout and
styling purposes
note that we are setting the key
property for this element to the
identifier property for each course
when using the map function it is always
a good idea to appropriately set the
react key property for the relevant
element like this this helps react to be
more efficient when considering the
component
we are also appropriately setting the
key property for the element here
related to each lesson we are setting
the key property here to the identifier
of each lesson
Let's test the code
okay we have an issue here so to fix
this issue we need to import the link
component from the react router Dom
package
we are using the link component to wrap
the title for each course
this is because we are going to create a
component responsible for displaying
course details for each individual
course in a bit
once this is done we'll point this link
to the relevant course component where
the details for the relevant individual
course will be outputted
this will allow a user to click the
header for a course and for the course
details for the relevant course to be
displayed after the user clicks the
relevant link on the home page
you can see we have four courses
currently saved to the system
so let's create a component that
displays the course details for a
particular course
so
from a ux user experience perspective
the user will click on the course
heading on the home page and will be
navigated to a component that displays
the course details for the relevant
course
let's create a folder named course
and a file within the course folder
named course.js
let's generate the boilerplate code for
the course component
let's open the app.js file and include
an appropriate route for our course
component
note that this component accepts a
parameter passed into the course
component
which is an identifier for a particular
course
so to tell the react router Dom system
as it were about the relevant identifier
parameter we can include a colon
followed by the name of the parameter
identifier at the end of the relevant
root path like this
let's go back to the course.js file
let's include the relevant Imports
I'm not going to explain this import
code as we have already covered this
while creating code for the other
components
all except for the use params hook
we are going to use the use params hook
to extract a parameter value that will
be passed into this component from the
home component when a user clicks on a
course heading
so let's create a value from the use
params hook
we can then use the params object to
retrieve the name of the parameter that
we named identifier
let's create a tracked variable named
course data we can use the set course
data function to change the state of the
course data variable
of course when the state of the variable
returned from the u-state hook has
changed this results in the relevant
component being re-rendered
let's use the use axios private hook
to get a reference to the axios client
where an Interceptor is employed to
inject the user's authentication details
into the HTTP header for any HTTP
request made using the axios client
returned from the use axios private hook
let's use the use effect talk so that we
can execute code that retrieves data for
the relevant course when the course
component first loads
let's use an alert to Output the results
returned from the relevant get request
within the home.js file let's include
the appropriate path to the course
component within the relevant link
component like this
note we are including the course
identifier as part of the path assigned
to the two property of the link element
Let's test the code
great the results are outputted through
a JavaScript alert the JavaScript alert
is of course just used for testing
purposes
let's create the UI code in the part of
the course component that returns jsx
code
so the code is very similar to the code
within the jsx section of the home
component so to speed things up I'm just
going to copy and paste the relevant
code from the home component
into the course component then let's
adapt the code appropriately for the
course component
so the difference between the relevant
code and the home component and the
relevant code in the course component is
that only one specific course is
displayed in the course component
whereas a list of all courses are
outputted from the home component
just a reminder if you get lost while
creating a code for any part of this
application please reference the code
that can be found at this location on
GitHub
note that for our course component we
are also including the instructor that
teaches the relevant course
this data is returned from the server in
the teacher property
so the course component only ever
returns one course rather than a list of
courses that are displayed within the
home component
so we copied this code from the home
component which is currently incorrect
for the course component we need to
replace the D variable here with course
data because the D references an item in
a list of courses in the home component
this course data variable represents one
particular course
excellent
the next component that I want to create
is used for the purpose of displaying
only the list of courses in which the
logged on user is enrolled
so let's create a folder within the
components folder named enrolled courses
within the enrolled courses folder let's
create a JavaScript file named enrolled
courses.js
let's copy and paste the relevant
imports from the home component
so for this component I'm going to copy
most of the code from the home component
as the code is very similar
the only difference is that we are
calling a different endpoint on the
server to get the relevant course data
in this case only a list of courses in
which the logged on user is enrolled
will be displayed to the user
just a reminder you can of course get
the finished code from the relevant
GitHub repository
let's include an appropriate root
component for the enrolled courses
component within the app.js file like
this
now let's open the header.js file and
include code so that a link to the home
component and the enrolled courses
component will appear within the
navigation bar at the top of the UI
in order for our links to be displayed
in white text let's include the
following properties within the navbar
element like this
so on smaller screens this navigation
bar doesn't currently look very good
so let's wrap the relevant navigation
elements within the nav collapse element
so that on smaller screens the
navigation bar responds appropriately
great
we copied this code from the home
component and we of course don't need
this code that outputs the hero image in
the enrolled courses component so let's
delete this code here
currently when we click on the enrolled
courses link no data is displayed
and this is an expected result because
the logged on user has not enrolled in
any courses
so let's create the functionality so
that a user can enroll in courses
we'll implement this functionality from
within the course component
so let's create code that displays a
button within the course component that
is labeled enroll
this button must only display if the
enrolled property for a particular
course object returns false
which denotes that the logged on user is
not currently the enrolled in the
relevant course
so when this button is clicked we want a
function named enroll to be executed the
code for this enroll function will of
course enroll the logged on user into
the relevant course
so let's create the enroll function
you can see that we are using a HTTP
post request
to post the course identifier wrapped in
an object to a specific end point the
server-side functionality written in
Java interacts with the neo4j database
management system appropriately in order
to create the appropriate relationship
between the user and the relevant course
so if the endpoint returns a status
response of 200 meaning success let's
display this message to the user which
simply thanks the user for enrolling in
the chosen course
then let's include code to navigate the
user to the enrolled courses component
Let's test this functionality
so each of the lessons listed for the
enrolled courses must have a play button
icon next to it when the user clicks the
play button icon the lesson that has
been created as a YouTube video will be
displayed to the user through the video
component that we are about to create
so the play button is implemented using
the font awesome icon component
the font awesome icon element is wrapped
by the link element the link elements to
property is set to the path of the video
component that we will create
the lessons identifier is passed in as a
parameter to the video component when
the relevant video link is clicked the
play button icon denotes this link on
the front end
so in the home component we are
currently handling what to Output to the
screen the hero image is displayed when
the user is not logged into the system
and a list of courses is displayed when
the user is logged into the system when
the user clicks the enrolled courses
link this is currently not being handled
appropriately
we want the login screen presented to
the user if the enrolled courses link is
clicked while the user is not logged
into the system
then when the user logs into the system
we want the user to be navigated to the
enrolled courses component rather than
the home component so let's implement
the code to handle this scenario
let's first create a component within
the components folder named required
auth
this component is responsible for
navigating the user to the login screen
if auth is null I.E the user is not
logged into the system
then let's open the app.js file and wrap
the enrolled courses root
with the required auth element like this
so the user will not be able to access
the enrolled courses component unless
the user is logged into the system if
the user tries to click the relevant
link the user will be presented with the
login screen so this forces the user to
log in in order to see the user's
enrolled courses and once the user logs
in the user is navigated directly to the
enrolled courses component
which means the user can see the list of
courses in which the user has been
enrolled within the login component we
need to create the navigation code
so that when the user logs in the user
is navigated to the component that the
user tried to access prior to being
redirected to the login screen in this
particular case this would be the
enrolled courses component
Let's test this code
great
so the last component that I want to
create is of course the video component
this component uses the react player
component to play the lessons that have
been created as videos on YouTube to the
user let's create a folder named video
let's create a file within this folder
named video.js
and let's create another file within the
video folder named video.css
the code for implementing the play video
functionality is very basic
let's use the use param hook
so that we can retrieve the YouTube
video ID that will be passed into the
component like this
let's open the app.js file and include
the appropriate route
so that the react router Dom system as
it were knows how to navigate the user
to the video component as well as pass
in the appropriate parameter to the
video component the parameter value will
be the YouTube video ID pertaining to
the relevant lesson
let's include the react player element
appropriately within the video component
so that the relevant YouTube video plays
immediately
we are setting the playing property to
true
for the react player element for this
purpose
then let's set the URL property
appropriately to point to the relevant
video on YouTube note that the URL
includes the YouTube ID that is passed
in as a parameter to this component
let's style the video component
appropriately
right let's test the code
I'd like to introduce you to this
exciting new Unity for beginners course
where we'll create a game using unity
and c-sharp over a series of videos
all the software that we'll use
including unity and vs code can be
downloaded free of charge
this course is totally free
hi and welcome I'm Gavin long the rigid
body component allows us to apply
physics to a game object for example
gravity but we are going to write code
in the update method to apply a forward
Force to the player game object in
response to the user pressing down the W
key on the user's keyboard
so to improve the user's experience you
can include a spinner that appears to
the user while data is being loaded so
in fact the last component that we'll
create could be the spinner component
so when the data is loading we present
the user with a spinner and then when
the relevant data becomes available the
spinner component disappears and the
data is displayed to the user
so for this purpose I've created a
spinner component
please reference the relevant code on
GitHub if you'd like to include the
spinner functionality within your
application
I'm going to fast forward the creation
of the spinner component as this is
purely a bonus piece of code that you
can study at your own pace if you are
interested to implement the spinner we
are simply creating a react component
relevant CSS code to style and animate
the spinner
and functionality within the relevant
components to appropriately show and
hide the spinner the showing and hiding
of the spinner is implemented using a
Boolean variable
where the state of the relevant variable
is tracked through the use of the use
statehook from within the relevant
components showing or hiding the spinner
please review the code in detail at the
relevant GitHub repository location
the link to the relevant repositories
available Below in the description of
this video
we can pass in the relevant Boolean
value as a prop to the spinner component
to indicate to the spinner component to
be visible or hidden like this
let's integrate the spinner component
into the enrolled courses component
hi and welcome I'm Gavin long
this is part two in a course where we'll
create a game using C sharp and unity in
part one I demonstrated the
potentially making the game at runtime
more robust for details on c-sharp data
types I've included a link to a c-sharp
tutorial on C sharp date
so I'm going to finish the code for this
application by styling the header of the
courses displayed in the home component
the course component and the enrolled
courses component
I'm including the relevant CSS classes
within the app.css file so that the
classes affect all of these components
I know the UI for this application is
not beautiful but the purpose of this
part of the course is to place an
application that takes advantage of a
neo4j graph database management system
for the purpose of managing
relationships between data entities
in the context of a web-based
application
my challenge to you is to Fork the
GitHub repository that contains the code
that I've demonstrated in this part of
the course and Abstract the common parts
of the jsx code contained in the home
component the course component and the
enrolled courses component into relevant
child components
one suggestion is to create a reusable
child component for an individual course
you can then use appropriate props to
dynamically customize the new child
course component based on its context
I.E its parent component for example in
the enrolled courses component a play
button appears next to every lesson for
each course
whereas in the home component these play
buttons are not included next to any of
the lessons for each course so the new
course child component will need to
account for these two scenarios and
dynamically output the appropriate jsx
code
I hope that you have enjoyed this part
of the course and have learned a little
bit about creating a client react
application that interfaces with a web
API component through axios where basic
authentication is employed thank you and
take care